So haben wir Quality Options, das Allerwichtigste, ohne Quality Options geht da hier nichts.
Ja, wir haben Quality Options, Poggers, Alter, huge, Pog, oh das Ganze ist ein bisschen groß,
ja Quality Options sind schon mal da, das ist das Allerwichtigste, geht nix, äh, was
ist mit YouTube los, auf dem zweiten Bildschirm, voll am Arschbacken gerade.
Okay, sehr schön, von Stardust, tja Leute, wow, das ist wieder so die Musik, die nicht
weiß wie laut sie sein will, geht's vor allem voll ab, wupp wupp wupp wupp, glaub so ist
besser, ja ne, ja ich hab's mir gerade der Vorschau angehört, so ist besser, RIP Server,
naja, wir müssen mal gucken, wir müssen mal gucken, also ich hab, also bevor wir anfangen,
ich muss ein bisschen was erzählen, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich einfach versuche
mal die alte Festplatte an den neuen rein zu hängen und gut ist, weil eigentlich wollte
ich das eh anders machen, den könnte ich auch die Kiste gleich neu installieren auf der
neuen Hardware, aber wir müssen die neue Hardware noch ein bisschen, mindestens rudimentär,
zusammenstecken, ich zeige euch mal ein Bild von Klay, wenn Twitch das gecheckt hat, dass
das Stream on ist, Trackstream, zwei Monate, Poggers, moin, der Deadlift ist am Start,
Prime Sub, huge, der IQ steigt heute unermesslich, ich seh das schon, komm mal geout, warum hab
ich eigentlich mein old, mein old emote nicht hier in meinem Imageboard drinne, also fail,
der ist aber richtig bonkersmoke, JiroSky, Twitch Prime, zwei Monate, ich frag mich,
wieviel Subs die meist abonnierten Channels hatten, bevor Twitch Prime, das wird mich
echt mal interessieren, weil mit Twitch Prime dürfte die Anzahl der Subs explodiert sein,
gibt es da so eine History-Kanal, nehmen wir mal DanceGaming oder so, guck mal, steht da
irgendwo die Subs drinne, ne, natürlich nicht, weil die Subs sind dann nicht öffentlich,
warum kriegt DanceGaming so wenig Follower, das kann doch überhaupt nicht sein, ist der
beste Let's Play-Channel, den es gibt, warum kriegt er so wenig Follower am Tag, das glaub
ich net, das ist doch nicht der richtige, doch, warum kriegt er so wenige Follower, war
der in den letzten Tagen nicht on, aber es gibt anscheinend keine Seite, wo das drinsteht,
wie lang braucht bitte mein Sub, ich guck mal in Streamlabs, ob ich den schon sehe,
also den Icon hast du schon mal, Xhut am Start, JiroSky, Twitch Prime, dankeschön, nö, Stellsoar,
du stehst auch noch nicht drinnen in Streamlabs, das hat Twitch nicht gecheckt, dass du resubbt
hast oder was auch immer, vielleicht hat Twitch heute auch Feiertag, also Leute, ich zeige
euch mal die Kiste, die RIP ist, ich bin gerade am Umbauen, ihr bei mir im Serverraum, den
serverraum kennt ihr ja noch, denke ich mal, hier den da, den kennt ihr wahrscheinlich
noch, so und das ist halt hier vorne, guckt hier, hier vorne ist das, Halbschatten, zwei
Monate fortlaufend, heute ist wirklich high IQ angesagt im Chat, bald ein neues Video
zum Serverraum, ja eigentlich wollte ich das machen, aber dazu wollte ich erstmal fertig
umbauen, ich mein so, wie das hier gerade aussieht, muss ich das Ding nicht filmen,
da komme ich ja kaum richtig rein, was ist genau kaputt, ich hab ehrlich gesagt, keine
Ahnung genau was kaputt ist, das Rack ist hier hinten, da, siehst du es doch, guck das
Rack da hinten, ist das hier, du siehst direkt, das ist die USB unten, die du siehst und
da ist die USB, naja, sag mal, kann die Musik, die kann sich echt nicht entscheiden, oder?
Die Musik kann sich nicht entscheiden von der Lautstärke, Phoenix, Twitch Prime, drei
Monate schon, Poggers, Poggers, Dobby, zwei Monate, wir kommen hier gar nicht mehr raus,
er, Neradon auch drei Monate am Start, das geht ja hier echt Schlag auf Schlag heute,
Heinrich auch Twitch Prime, meine Güte, jetzt geht es aber echt los hier, das ist wirklich
high high Q-Chat heute, Q-Chat extrem, Server nach fünf Minuten bezahlt, ich hab ja schon
alles hier, naja, also zumindest, die USB ist mir draufgefallen auf das Mainboard, ich hab
auch schon alles abgemacht, das war, wie gesagt, das liegt normalerweise nicht hier, ich hab
das schon alles ausgebaut, weil eigentlich ist mein Plan, ich wollte das in ein Gehäuse
einbauen und hier oben an die Wand, also da, da oben an die Wand, wollte ich eigentlich
noch ein paar Regale hin machen, weil der Raum ist ziemlich, ziemlich groß, was für
Kabel, ja, das sind die ganzen Kabel, die halt hier drinnen sind, plus noch mehr mittlerweile,
so und jetzt, das Ziel war eigentlich, dass ich den Krams raus mache, der hier so rumgelegen
hat, beziehungsweise überflüssig ist, beispielsweise das alte Kabelmodem raus und da ist, da ist
viel Crap drin, die ganzen Aufnahmen, die ganzen Fernsehaufnahmekarten und so, brauch
ich nicht, oh Stellzoar, jetzt zeigt das an Poggers, jetzt hat er es kapiert, zwei Monate,
dankeschön, so und dann wollte ich, wenn ich das schon sauber gemacht hab, wollte ich
hier oben zwei Regale hin machen, was natürlich auch ganz gut ist, wenn der ganze Staub nicht
auf das Zeug drauf fällt und dann ist gut, so und das Problem ist jetzt nur gewesen,
ich hatte das schon alles schon schön ausgebaut, äh, warum steht nichts rein, lasst du alle
ein bisschen, keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht, sollte eigentlich drinstehen, zumindest, ähm,
ich hatte schon alles raus und die alte USB wollte ich endlich mal auf den Müll, äh,
ok, die alte USB wollte ich endlich mal auf den Müll schmeißen und man sieht es ja hier,
ich kann in den Raum nicht richtig rein, ne, also ohne, dass ich auf Zeug drauf drehte,
deswegen hab ich hier vorne gestanden, das hier ist der Türrahmen, deswegen hab ich
hier vorne in der Tür, in der Tür, in der Tür gestanden, wollte halt die USB aufheben
und ihr seht schon, die ist auf manchen Seiten staubig, die steht da schon ewig rum in der
Ecke und wollte das hochheben und irgendwie ist es bald runtergerutscht und auf das Ding
drauf gefallen.
So und das Ding wiegt keine Ahnung, 30 Kilo oder so, der Scheiß ist schwer, ups, the fuck,
nix der Anfälle bei, wieso lag das Mainboard jetzt da, ja weil ich es noch nicht rausgeräumt
hab, das lag halt einfach da, es ist ja auch schon alles ab, ich hab, ich hab nur Glück
gehabt, dass es nicht auf das Ram drauf gefallen ist, zumindest, ich hab keine Ahnung ehrlich
gesagt was genau kaputt ist, also ich seh den Board, wartet mal, ok ich hab keine Ahnung
wo ich den geschmissen hab, zumindest es geht nicht mehr an, also es geht noch an und wenn
ich die Tastatur anschließe, die wird auch mit Strom versorgt und alles, aber die wird
nicht mehr als USB Gerät erkannt und der Bildschirm geht auch nicht an, also im Prinzip,
würde ich sagen, ist das Ding ziemlich, ziemlich RIP.
Es sieht vollkommen ok aus, also ich vermute mal, dass das entweder, wobei kann eigentlich
nicht sein, ich wollt grad sagen, dass ich irgendwas kurz geschlossen hab, wenn ich es
wieder angeschaltet hab, aber danach war es ja nix, war ja nix mehr, oder aber es wird
wahrscheinlich irgendeinen Widerstand oder, keine Ahnung, es wird wahrscheinlich irgendwas
geplatzt sein, na klar der Ram, was sonst, das Ram, es ist egal, das oder der Ram geht
alles, der Speicher oder das Memory, egal, der Gerät, im Zweifelsfall der Gerät, genau,
der Kupfermann, Twitch Prime, 3 Monate, im fortlaufenden Monat, ai ai ai, hab ich noch
was übersehen hier, nee da stellt so was jetzt auch am Start, der Kupfermann 3 Monate,
dankeschön, also zumindest, es lässt sich da grad auch nix machen, wenn ich es einschalte,
ich hab extra mal so nen, so nen Energy Meter Ding angeschlossen, da geht auch direkt hoch
auf, auf 7, 8 Watt Stromverbrauch, das brauchen diese Boards normalerweise auch, Strom geht
auch an, aber es kommt halt kein Bild, und die Tastatur wird auch nicht erkannt, ich
hab mir überlegt, ob es vielleicht bringt, wenn ich es irgendwie mal resette oder so,
aber ganz ehrlich, wenn das Board nicht mehr angeht, das hat natürlich auch kein Speaker
oder irgendwas, also ich hab keine Ahnung, was mit dem Board ist, es geht zumindest nicht
mehr an, so, aber eigentlich ist es auch nicht so schlimm, äh, wozu war das Board, da war
ein Heimautomatisierungszeug dran, also sprich, da war das Z-Wave Stick dran, da war das Funk-Ding
für die Rolle hinten dran, da war die Erkennung, wo ich grad mit meinem iPhone bin, ob ich
auf dem Weg heim oder zurück bin, da war die Steuerung für meinen WLAN Access Points
drauf, also Steuerung stimmt nicht, die Admin Oberfläche, das Ding läuft immer noch, auch
ohne Admin Oberfläche, ich kann da grad nix einstellen, ähm, es war ein bisschen Auswertungskram
drauf, aber ich hab ja vor einer Weile angefangen, meine ganze Technik ein bisschen auseinander
zu ziehen, äh, wenn ihr euch noch an das alte Video erinnert, Musik, Musik, kannst du dich
mal entscheiden, ob laut oder leise, wäre das möglich?
Nee, irgendwie können die sich nicht wirklich entscheiden, also, ähm, so, und wie man das
hier sieht, in dem alten Video, wie gesagt, das ist ja von 2017, da hatte ich ja noch diese
große Kiste, die steht zwar immer noch da, aber die macht nicht mehr so viel, ich hab
das mittlerweile alles aufgeteilt, ja, also Internet und Netzwerkgeduld macht ein extra
Router, ähm, die Heimautomatisierungsgeschichte läuft über eine extra, über eine extra Geschichte
und, ähm, Fernsehaufnahme-Kram läuft auch, Media Center-Kram läuft auch über eine extra
Geschichte, also, es ist jetzt grad nicht so wild, das ist, das ist von 2017, ja, das
Video ist von 2017, so, ähm, also es ist nicht so wild, im Prinzip lief nur das Heimautomatisierungszeug
drauf, allerdings ist das auch ein bisschen doof, wenn das nicht funktioniert, weil ich
hab keine Kameras, also ich hab weder die Kameras am, am, am, im, im Hof zum Eingang
hin, noch dort, wo sich die Katze immer ablegt, da guck ich morgens immer, so was es so treibt,
äh, noch hab ich den ganzen Status von Fenster auf, äh, Türen auf, zu, ähm, die Rollen
gehen nicht mehr automatisch auch, äh, hoch, mein Positions-Tracking und so, also, es
ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir hier abkratzen würden, weil die Kiste nicht mehr geht, aber
es ist schon ein bisschen nervig, deswegen ist es jetzt auch nicht so extrem akut, dass
man das innerhalb der nächsten paar Stunden wieder hinkriegen muss, äh, deswegen dachte
ich mir, ich, keine Kameras, sag mal deine Adresse, 127001 Eats, easy, ähm, zumindest,
es wär schon gut, wenn ich es wieder hinkriege, ja, ähm, nach Möglichkeit guck ich mal, ich,
ich bin, wie gesagt, ich bin noch hin und her gerissen, entweder probier ich mal die
alte Platte dran zu hängen und gucken, ob alles startet und gut ist, was ich aber viel
lieber machen würde, ihr könnt euch ja noch dran erinnern, wo wir so ein 10, äh, wo wir
unser 10 Gigabit NAS zusammengestellt haben, das Ding hab ich ja immer noch nicht gebaut,
aber ich hab die ganze Hardware hier und jetzt zeig ich euch mal ein Foto, ich hab schon
ein bisschen, ich hab mal alles auf einen Haufen geschmissen, was wir jetzt bauen,
was wir jetzt machen könnten, so, ich geb zu, sieht nicht schön aus, ja, es sieht nicht
schön aus, die neue Kiste, ähm, ach ja, ich kann euch übrigens, ne, wenn ihr wirklich
was Zuverlässiges haben wollt, dann, ähm, also wirklich was, was gut funktioniert, dann
kauft nicht das billigste und kauft euch vielleicht irgendwie einen fertigen, äh, äh, Miniserver
von Dell oder HP oder sowas, ähm, aber ich, ich bastel halt gerne, ähm, so, was gab's,
es gab ein paar Fragen im Chat, Dragstreamfragen, sag mal, hast du eine Empfehlung, muss bald
mal meinem Vater ein neues Heimnetz einrichten, muss einzelne Telefonleitungen, drei Access,
alter, dieser Musikstream, der fuckt mich übelst ab, weil die Musik, nicht weiß, ob
sie laut, warte mal, so, ja, so ist gut, ähm, äh, drei Access-Points und zwei LAN-Anschlüsse,
was, was, muss bald mal bei meinem Vater ein neues Heimnetz, muss einzelne Telefonleitungen,
drei Access-Points und zwei LAN-Anschlüsse haben, ich wüsste, mir fällt kein Netzwerkgerät
ein, was, nur zwei Netzwerk-Ports, okay, das check ich nicht, das, das klingt, wie nach
einer 0-15-Fritzbox oder sowas, was du haben willst, äh, Cutler Joe sagt, sorry, wenn
das gerade ein bisschen am Thema vorbeigeht, aber, unsere Firma wurde von diesem Emotet
befallen, ist es dieses Encryption-Ding, äh, wie lange schätzt du, bis das wieder läuft,
ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das hängt, das hängt von den Leuten
da vor Ort ab und was das genau macht, keine Ahnung, X-Shadow-X-Ghost, Twitch Prime, drei
Monate, Vollgas, was sagst du zum Preis vom neuen i9 10980XE, nicht mal so schlecht, ich
hab, weiß ich auch nicht, hab mich ja nicht geguckt, ich hatte Probleme mit meiner Kiste,
die kaputt ist, da hab ich andere Sachen angeguckt, das einzige, was ich gemacht hab, ich hab jetzt
mein Video zu aufgenommen, weil da Fanto was zu seinen Weißheitszenen gepostet hat, aber
ansonsten, muss ich mich erstmal mit meiner eigenen Technik rumschlagen, ähm, was kostet
es denn, die sind immer ganz gut, übrigens die Leute finden, dass das Weißheitszahn-Video
übelst eklig, ich hab grad, ich hab instant 15 Deabos gekriegt wegen dem Weißheitszahn-Video,
weil die alle gesagt haben, Max, Woodface, das ist ja eklig, gehste zu Halloween im Furry
Kostüm los, ja bestimmt, ich mach Vars Cosplay oben ohne, ähm, wo steht denn was es kostet,
18 Core unter 1000, na gut, das braucht kein Mensch daheim, und was kostet es denn, ach
hier, na gut, das kann man fast mehr oder weniger 1 zu 1 in Euro übersetzen, ok, im Vergleich
zum alten ist es schon eine ganze Ecke billiger, das stimmt, ähm, wie siehts denn mit Takt
aus, jetzt haben wir 18 Cores, all Cores sind Turbo Boost, ey, das ist gar nicht schlecht,
es braucht auch hier Flintstone, es braucht auch keiner, denn das Retripper für daheim,
16 Kerne ist total, ne, 18, 18, nicht 16, 18, das ist total beknackt daheim, äh, Trackstream,
das ist die Frage, was du brauchst, also wenn du Access Points brauchst, wie gesagt, da
kann ich dir nur, äh, Ubiquiti, wir haben uns ja letztens angekauft, wie man den ganzen
Kram ausspricht, Access Points empfehlen, und als Router nehme ich eben für dich irgendeine
Mikrotik Ding nehmen, aber es ist die Frage, was du für ein Internetanschluss hast, wenn
es VDSL ist, kannst du den VDSL Modem kaufen, und anschließen, oder wenn es Kabel ist, musst
du gucken, wie du das mit der Kiste vom Provider machst, also wahrscheinlich brauchst du einen
Router, einen Switch, je nachdem, wieviel Netzwerkgeräte das sind, ähm, und, und drei Access Points,
und eventuell noch einen DSL Modem, muss man, muss man gucken, was, was genau ist, jemand,
das ist, also, das ist okay, ich meine, daheim brauchst, daheim braucht's wirklich keiner,
die Sache ist die, ähm, es ist auch reichlich, reichlich unsinnig irgendwo, ja, also das
Geld hast du auf jeden Fall besser eine ordentliche Grafikkarte investiert zusätzlich, als, ähm,
noch mal eine stellere CPU zu kaufen, wenn man natürlich im Heimbereich da Anwendungszwecke
für hat, wenn man irgendeine fette Kiste hat, und was auch immer da drauf macht, dann warum
nicht, ja, aber preislich ist anscheinend ganz okay, ich weiß gar nicht, was kostet
denn der aktuelle Threadripper, der so ungefähr in dieser, in dieser Region spielt, was ist
deiner Meinung nach der beste DOCSIS Router, ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, außer
der Fritzbox, äh, von, von Router, die ein eingebautes, ähm, Kabelmodem haben, ich würde
gucken, ob ich nicht mir einen stink normalen Router hole, und das Kabelmodem davor stelle,
von Unity Media oder von wem es doch immer ist, weil, was ich letztens gelesen habe,
dass die Connectbox von Unity Media, die kann jetzt einen Bridge Mode, das heißt man kann
die Connectbox von Unity Media einfach an seinen, äh, Router anschließen, wahrscheinlich,
ich hab's noch nicht ausprobiert, ja, wahrscheinlich kann man aber die Connectbox einfach an seinen
Router stöpseln, und gut, es, und dann würde ich natürlich wie immer, ihr kennt mich ja,
mittlerweile für den Heimgebrauch ein Mikrotik Hex PoE empfehlen, so für irgendwie 50 Euro,
bester Router, Preis-Leistung und hat sogar noch PoE am Start.
Unity Media meldet fatale Sicherheitslücke in Routern, ok, jetzt gucken wir uns mal kurz
an, eigentlich wollte ich ja die neue Kiste zusammenbauen, ich sag's nur mal so, ähm,
wann kam das, 2.10.00 gestern, viele Unity Media Kunden gehen über eine Connectbox online,
darin hat ein Sicherheitsforschung eine folgenschwere Sicherheitslücke entdeckt, ich hatte folgenschwere
Warenmillionen Router, wisst ihr Leute, manchmal bin ich echt froh, dass ich dahinter noch
meine eigene Kiste stehen hab, ja, und mich nicht auf dieses Unity Media Zeug verlasse.
Die Schwachstelle klafft im Web-Interface des Routers, wir entdecken ein Sicherheitser...
warum ist das Web-Interface überhaupt noch außen offen?
Ne, Moment, das muss man jetzt mal lesen, was du... ok, ähm, über das Web-Interface
kann man einen Ping oder einen Trace-Route durchführen, um zu überprüfen, ob die Internetverbindung
intakt ist, ja das stimmt, das hab ich auch schon ausprobiert, ähm, also führt der Router
die gleichnamigen Shell-Befehle, oh nee, oder, oh nee, oh nee, ich muss gar nicht weiterlesen,
Alter, Unity Media, also im Prinzip, ähm, ich überleg grad, ob ich euch die Connectbox
zeigen kann, also im Prinzip hast du da einfach ne Sicherheitsbox, ne Kiste, da kannst du
dann eingeben, hier, da gibst du die IP ein, so, und im Prinzip würd ich dann sowas hier
machen, oder sowas, Alter, Unity Media, come on brah, aber ok, warum das ein großes Problem
ist, hab ich aber immer noch nicht verstanden, man muss ja erstmal auf das Web-Interface
drauf, dazu führt der Router die gleichnamigen Shell-Befehle auf sein Erwähnungssystem aus,
laut XITAN werden dabei die Nutzer-Eingaben jedoch nicht ausreichend gefilmt, so ist
es möglich weitere Befehle über die Funktion, das ist ok, das ist scheiße, aber das ist
noch nicht großartig kritisch, ne, du brauchst immer noch den Login auf das Web-Interface,
du musst vom internen Netzwerk kommen, äh, Morris1610 abonniert schon 3 Monate auf Stufe
1, ein richtiger, richtiger Sub, kein, kein, sondern ein richtiger, ein echter, dankeschön,
3 Monate echter Sub, big brain, Alter, big brain, massive, äh, ok, wo ist das, wo ist
das Problem jetzt, bei der Ping-Funktion, bei der Ping-Funktion etwa nimmt der Router
zu pingende IP-Adresse als Nutzer-Handler, das ist, Leute, ich hab's nicht gelesen und
was hab ich hier oben instinktiv geschrieben, bam, Simicolor, das war klar, äh, kann er
beliebige weitere Befehle folgen lassen, die den Router anschließen, Moment, was, welche
Schnittstelle, der meint über die Rest-API vom, oder, oder, oder, API vom, vom Web-API
vom Router oder was, ok, zu einem fatalen Sicherheitswert ist das, das ist bis jetzt
wirklich, es ist scheiße, aber es ist noch kein großartiges Problem, ist die Frage,
wie man, warum man das ausfällt, was, welche Schnittstelle, was zum Teufel, what, äh,
was für eine Schnittstelle denn, ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet, warum hat das Ding
überhaupt noch mal eine Schnittstelle, ich mein, das Ding hat Web-Interface, also würde
ich vermuten, auf dem gleichen Port lauscht halt irgendwie so ein bisschen API-Gedöns,
wo man halt, wo man halt irgendwelche Posts und Gats und Zeugs, HTTP-Gedöns hinschicken
kann, ähm, und die API braucht keine, braucht keine Authentifizierung, oder was, ja, warum
braucht die API keine Authentifizierung, das ist ja absolut total beknackter Kram.
Der Code zum Filtern, ja, ja, aber das bringt den Router noch lange nicht dazu, die Sachen
auszuführen.
Nee, nee, das steht da nicht, da steht nicht jedoch die Schnittstelle, über die man Ping-
und RaceRoute-Funktionen ausführen kann, und dann ist die Frage, also, ist es was Extranes,
oder sind diese API-Aufrufe, über die man Ping- und RaceRoute hinschickt, sind die,
wir müssen uns mal die Originalveröffentlichung gleich angucken, das haben die hoffentlich
verlinkt, ähm, sind die API-Aufrufe an den Router, sind die nicht Session, Passport,
wie auch immer geschützt.
Befindet sich ein Angreifer im gleichen lokalen Netz, kann er deshalb auch ohne Kenntnis
das Admin Passworts beliebige Systembefehle ausführen, das ist ziemlich beknackter.
Okay, auf diese Weise könnte ein Angreifer potenziell den Internetverkehr ausspielen,
ich muss mal kurz was aufschreiben, ich muss gerade mal gucken, ob ich überhaupt den Traffic
geploggt habe von WLAN zu Netzwerk, wo der Router drin steht, sonst könnte man theoretisch,
wenn man im WLAN ist, ich meine außer mir ist keiner im WLAN, aber man weiß ja nicht,
welcher Server ist eigentlich kaputt, der hier, ne, der hier, RIP, ähm, okay, also weiter,
auf diese Weise könnte ein Angreifer potenziell den Internetverkehr ausspielen oder den Router
zum Teil, ja gut, das stimmt, ich muss mal kurz gucken, was meine Connectbox überhaupt
für eine IP hat, was haben die Dinge auch standardmäßig, eins, das ist die Connectbox,
willkommen zurück, okay, das ist die Connectbox, probiere ich gerade mal aus, ob ich da theoretisch
hinkommen würde, von meinem, vom Smartphone aus, oder ob ich sinnvolle Firewallregeln
gemacht habe, ich glaube ich habe keine sinnvollen Firewallregeln gemacht, siehst du Leute, da
hätten wir schon ein Problem, sobald jetzt jemand bei mir im WLAN drinne ist, das Passwort
ist sichtbar, es ist, es ist wirklich Massive Big Brain Unity Media, Massive, Massive Brain,
dass man das hier reinschreibt, ja, okay, also, dann muss ich jetzt mal kurz auf meinen
Router und nochmal ein paar Firewallregeln einschalten, das ist mir nämlich gerade so
eingefallen, und zwar gehen wir jetzt mal auf IP, Firewall, warum habe ich denn das
netgeplockt, ich muss das plocken, ich muss alles vom WLAN, ich muss alles vom WLAN plocken,
alles vom WLAN, was zu Netz 192.168.0 geht, WLAN 1.337, ja, da kann ich es ja wenigstens
merken, WLAN 1 ist Default, WLAN 1.337 ist China WLAN, ja, warum 1.337, weil das, weil
das Elite ist, aber ich bilde mir ein, ich hatte mal so eine Regel gemacht, okay, ne,
da ist was anderes, Invalid Drop Forward, ja gut, da muss ich mal gucken, welche, welche,
ah hier, das ist die Regel, die ist wichtig, aber die müsste ich einschränken, aktuell
sage ich, von Default WLAN, also das ist das normale Netz, wo meine, was verdienst du
für ein Brutto im Jahr 200k, nein, WTF, 200k würde ich gerne verdienen, ich müsste hier
eigentlich so eine Regel drüber machen, die das ganze verbietet, weil das hier, das hier
ist eine, sag mal, so, das macht ja nichts anderes, wie erlauben, dass ich vom WLAN ins
Internet darf, und was man ja in der Firewall-Riegel nicht machen kann ist, einzustellen, jede
einzelne IP, die erlaubt ist, das ergibt ja, das ergibt ja eigentlich keinen Sinn, deswegen,
plus 300k YouTube, easy, halbe Million im Jahr, kein Problem, deswegen geht natürlich
auch aus dem WLAN auf das Managementnetz von der Connectbox, heißt auf die IP, das heißt,
wir machen jetzt einfach mal noch eine Firewall-Riegel und sagen, dass das immer verboten ist, außer
man kommt aus dem internen Netz, also quasi wenn in Interface, ach so, ich hab übrigens
meine Interface immer noch nicht richtig benannt, weil BigBrain, also meine ganzen Interfaces
heißen ziemlich beknackt, die heißen dann sowas wie WLAN1-Dings oder Bridge1 oder sonst
was, also richtig hängen geblieben, ich müsste das echt mal alles ordentlich benennen, weil
ganz ehrlich, ich blicke da langsam selbst nicht mehr durch, und in Firewall-Riegel nicht
durchblicken ist eigentlich ziemlich doof. Was Chat? Okay, also wir machen jetzt mal
eine neue Firewall-Riegel und zwar, wir verbieten in Interface ist das interne, die interne
Bridge, ich hoffe, das stimmt jetzt, Bridges, ja Bridge, Bridge ist das interne Netzwerk-Ding,
okay, schön, dass ich das jetzt alles ordentlich benannt habe, also wenn Input-Interface
nicht meine interne Bridge ist, da hieß das Stream plötzlich aus, ja, das könnte schon,
das könnte schon passieren, ne? Ne, kann eigentlich nicht passieren, so, Out-Interface
ist, Moment, Out-Interface-List ist ins Internet raus und Destination-Address, darf man eigentlich
sowas hier machen, muss ich mal gucken, wobei, wobei, können wir das nicht schöner machen?
Ey doch, das müsste eigentlich funktionieren, wir könnten, wir könnten, wir könnten ne
Gruppe anlegen, wo alle privaten Netzwerke drin sind, aber egal, wir machen jetzt mal
nur das dann, darf man, darf man sowas hier machen, ist das legit? Gleich ist das Stream
das Ganze, also von der Idee her sollte das jetzt nix machen, außer, dass es verboten
ist, ich musste es übrigens noch auf Reject stellen, also es wird alles verboten, es wird
alles verboten, was nicht, also es wird alles getropped oder Rejected, was nicht von meinem
internen Netzwerk-Interface kommt, was raus aus dem Internet-Interface will und als Zielnetz
eben das da hat, so, okay, das können wir jetzt relativ weit oben machen, geht das Internet
noch, Internet geht noch, okay, nice, schauen wir mal, ob es vom Handy noch funktioniert,
also vom Handy funktioniert das Internet und vom Handy aus funktioniert, gucken wir mal,
ob ich auf die Fritz, nicht auf die Fritzbox, auf die Connectbox noch komme, das sollte
jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr funktionieren, funktioniert nicht mehr, okay, nice, das haben
wir schon mal behoben und dadurch, dass es eine Reject-Regel ist, weiß ich auch, dass
ich mir garantiert nichts eingefangen habe, eingefangen könnte, was ich jetzt aus Versehen
mehr erlaubt habe oder so, okay, lesen wir mal weiter, was die schreiben zur Connectbox,
also das kann jetzt bei mir schon mal nicht mehr passieren, weil außer aus dem internen
Admin-Netz kommt man jetzt nicht mehr zur Connectbox, da habe ich mir ehrlich gesagt
überhaupt keine Gedanken drüber gemacht, dass ich eigentlich auch das Netz verbieten
sollte, wo die Connectbox und Fritzbox und Gedöns drinnen hängt, was war denn das Ziel
der Regel, das Ziel der Regel war, dass ich aus jedem Netz außer meinem internen Netz
nicht mehr auf das Netz drauf zugreifen kann, wo die Connectbox und die Fritzbox drinnen
steht, so Bridge ist mein internes Interface, das ist das Ausgangsinterface vom Router,
wo dann auch die Fritzbox und die Connectbox dahinter hängt und das ist das Netz, was
verboten sein soll, also das passt eigentlich, ernsthafte Frage an den Programmierer, 3
Zahlen, Zahl gleich 6, Zahl 2 gleich 4, Zahl 3 gleich 9, was, wieso ist if Zahl, ich kenne
keine Programme, na doch das geht, das ist natürlich doof geschrieben hier, eigentlich
wollten wir bringen Server bauen, also das ist eine interessante Frage hier im Chat,
lass mal gucken, also ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das überhaupt syntaktisch okay ist, aber
gehen wir mal von aus, dass es syntaktisch okay wäre, dann sind das hier ja, da muss
man sich fragen, in welcher Reihenfolge das Ganze ausgewertet wird und in der Regel hast
du in im im, nennen wir das mal im Handbuch oder in der offiziellen Dokumentation zu einer
Programmiersprache oder zur spezifischen Implementierung dieser Programmiersprache,
drinne stehen, welcher Operator, also sprich das Ding in dem Fall, Vorrang hat vor anderen
Operator, so nachdem das hier alles der gleiche Operator ist, also kleiner als, oder kleiner,
ist die Frage, stellt sich nicht, die Operator haben alle gleich viel Vorrang, deswegen wird
das ganze von links nach rechts ausgewertet, das bedeutet, Zahl eins ist sechs, Zahl zwei
ist vier, Zahl drei ist neun, das heißt, der guckt zuerst mal, also so würde ich das
gehen, kommt ein bisschen auf die Programmiersprache an, aber normalerweise sollte es, sollte es
eigentlich so funktionieren, Zahl eins kleiner Zahl zwei, stimmt das was ich erzähle, ja
zumindest, Zahl eins kleiner Zahl zwei, so Zahl sechs kleiner zwei, das ist, das ist
true, ne, warte mal, Zahl sechs, Schwachsinn, das ist false, das ist false, also, ok wenn
das C ist, dann ist es null, aber sagen wir mal so false, ne das würde in C-Sharp gar
nicht funktionieren, das würde glaube ich so in C-Sharp gar nicht funktionieren, aber
gehen wir mal davon aus, das wäre C, false, und jetzt ist drei, neun, und neun ist größer
als null, deswegen kommt da false raus, in C-Sharp wird das ganze nicht funktionieren,
alter Notepad, Notepad, oh meine Güte, warum mache ich das überhaupt in so einem Kack-Editor,
jetzt mal ernsthaft, ne, so in C-Sharp würde das wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren, weil
der wäre so clever und würde erkennen, dass hier das Ergebnis dieses Vergleichs true oder
false ist, und dann würde er sagen, ich kann Boolean nicht vergleichen mit Int, das würde
aber funktionieren, oder, ne ich glaube man kann auch keine Boole schiften, hab ich noch
nie ausprobiert, the fuck, was zeug, aber ich glaube es sollte jetzt klar sein, warum
true rauskommt, oder, ja genau, einfach weil neun größer als null ist, richtig, ist das
nicht so ähnlich wie der Unterschied zwischen, oder, oder, oder, boah, ja im Prinzip schon,
also oder ist quasi der logische Vergleich, also ist quasi, ist das und das oder was kommt
da raus, also irgendwie den Ausdruck, am besten ist, die Sachen immer zu klammern, dann weiß
man nämlich auch automatisch, was da irgendwie passiert, also das ist ja im Prinzip ein logisches
oder, das hier ist, was ist denn das überhaupt, ein Bitwise, Bitwise or, wahrscheinlich ist
das, wahrscheinlich ist das, ja, wahrscheinlich ist das ein Bitwise or, das heißt das würde
an der Stelle dann auch meckern, weil ich denke, ich hab es ehrlich gesagt noch nie
probiert, ob man Boole's, von der Theorie her kannst du Boole's natürlich super Bitwise
Dingsen, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das erlaubt ist, ehrlich gesagt, also ich bin ja noch nie
auf Ideen gekommen, keine Ahnung, war schon nie ausprobiert, also ich hab keine Ahnung,
ob man in C-Sharp sowas machen darf, so irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so, oder so, oder, oder, oder,
oder, oder so, ich hab keine, wahrscheinlich nicht, wahrscheinlich geht das nicht, ich
mein, von der Logik her wäre es denkbar, dass das funktioniert, aber ich glaube nicht,
das ist ihnen, das ist ihnen wahrscheinlich einfach zu, nicht, nicht, wie sagen sie immer
so schön, nicht explicit genug, dass man es checkt. Die Frage wurde im Chat schon vor
mindestens, mindestens dreimal beantwortet, aber ich bin ja nicht der Chat. Also kann
ich hier nicht alles verfolgen, was so im Chat steht. Hat jemand eine Idee, wie man effektiv
testen kann, ob eine Zahl eine Primzahl ist? Dieses Thema wurde, glaube ich, mehr behandelt
als so ziemlich jedes andere Thema. Oh Nicky, 30, drei Monate, jetzt hab ich alles
übersehen hier. Poggers, Dankeschön. So, wen hab ich noch übersehen hier? Hab ich
überhaupt noch einen übersehen? Morris eigentlich, nee, Morris, dich hatte ich schon, oder? Der
Heinrich hat Subscribed vor 39 Minuten, hab ich gar nicht gesehen. Heinrich Poggers. So,
wir wollten uns aber eigentlich die Sicherheitsglocke bei Unity Media als angucken und noch eigentlicher
wollten wir eine neuen Server installieren. Nur mal so angemerkt, ne. Ebenbei. War das
eigentlich Sinn und Zweck der Übung vom Streben. Ja, aber wir machen hier oft Sachen, die nicht
geplant sind. Ja, Trackstream, das kommt auf die Sprache an. Das kommt auf die Sprache
an, je nachdem, was das bedeutet. Also ich glaube in Python ist das so, wie du es sagst.
In C-Sharp ist es definitiv nicht so. In C-Sharp geht ein normales Oder, also ein einfaches
Pipe gar nicht an den meisten Stellen. Warum englisches Tastatur layout ist es gar nicht,
die Sprache ist Englisch und das Keyboard ist Deutsch. Weil man viel einfacher nach
Naja, das stimmt schon. Das englische Tastatur layout ist nicht verkehrt, aber auf der deutschen
Tastatur. Es ist Gewöhnungssache. Es ist Gewöhnungssache. Zum, wenn du programmierst, ist es nicht schlecht,
weil du so Sachen wie eckige Klammern und so halt auf ordentlichen, also eckige Klammern
hast du glaube ich auf dem englischen Layout hier auf dem da. Glaub ich jetzt, bin ich
mir grad nicht ganz sicher. Ich glaube hier hast du die. Ist auch egal, wir gucken uns
jetzt mal an, was Unity Media dazu sagt. Ok, das haben wir soweit gelesen. Befinden sich
ein Angreifer im gleichen lokalen Netz, kann er deshalb auch ohne Kenntnis das Admin-Passwort
von beliebigen Systembefehlen ausführen und das Empfehlung des Routers manipulieren. Auf
diese Weise könnte ein Angreifer potenziell hinterhand verkehrt auch schon über zum Teil
einen Spotter. Geil. Wahnsinn. So fail. Das ist mega fail Unity Media, was ist mit euch
los, ja. Also das ist wirklich fail. Die Sache ist, also das Ding ist ja auf mehreren Ebenen
fail. Dass es nicht richtig escaped ist, ist das eine, aber das viel schlimmere ist, dass
du einfach beliebige Befehle an irgendeinen APN-Punkt von dem Router schicken kannst ohne
jegliche Authentifizierung und es einfach funktioniert. Das ist richtig fail. Offenbar
auch über das Internet ausnutzbar, ok. Darüber hinaus berichtet der Sicherheitsforscher,
dass es mehrere tausende Betroffenen über die Geräte... anscheinend sind die Geräte
auch über das Internet akkupieren, die Fernwartungsfunktion. Die habe ich hoffentlich nicht aktiv, woran
sieht man das, ob man die aktiv hat? Woran sieht man, ob die Fernwartungsfunktion aktiv
ist? Aber ich habe sie nicht eingeschaltet, also nicht wissentlich jetzt. Woher weiß
man, ob die Fernwartungsfunktion... ok, warte mal. Connectbox Fernwartung. Warum hat das
Ding überhaupt? Eine Fernwartungsfunktion. Äh, nicht Connectbox. Fernzugriff auf Connectbox.
Warum hat das sowas überhaupt? Die Firma wurde bereits auf 95... Blablabla. Wer überprüfen
möchte, ob die eigene X-Connectbox noch anfällig ist, findet bei... ach, cool. Das
können wir ausprobieren. Die Fall ist hier aus, sonst den Webhinterface ja eingeschaltet
habe ich es nicht. Ok, probieren wir mal aus, ob meine Connectbox anfällig ist. Ich weiß
aber nicht, ob ich das on stream machen soll, ehrlich gesagt. Ok, Disconnect. Das da ist
das Richtige. Ok, wir können uns ja mal angucken, wie das funktioniert. Das ist ja sehr übersichtlich.
Wie gesagt, Python ist ja mittlerweile schon voll die krasse Hexorsprache. Also die meisten
mittlerweile, ein riesen Teil, wenn es jetzt nicht gerade irgendwelche Low-Level-Geschichten
sind, aber die meisten Sachen hast du mittlerweile. Entweder ist es halt die klassische C-Geschichte,
wenn es irgendwelche Low-Level-Geschichten sind, wo du speichermäßig machen musst,
das ist Python. Mittlerweile ist es wirklich die Wissenschafts- und Hexorsprache. Ok, also
was macht der denn hier? Parameter, Router, IP, Command, Sessions, Get, das was wir eingegeben
haben. Ok, Zertifikate überprüfen falsch, äh, falsch. Wir überprüfen kein Zertifikat,
wir taucken Set Cookie, Set Cookie. Äh, der holte sich das, holte sich das Session, Session
taucken oder irgendwie sowas da raus. Ja, ich würde sagen, der holt sich das, der holt
sich irgendwie, irgendwie Session taucken oder irgendwas da raus, das ist mir jetzt
gerade, müssen wir mal gucken, wie das Ganze aufgebaut ist. Get Set Cookie, blaaa, Find,
Index, Set Cookie, Find, der holt sich irgendwie den Wert von Set Cookie aus, aus den HTTP-Headers
raus. So, dann Session ID oder was auch immer auf Minus 1, so und jetzt kommt das Interessante,
Token ist dann, ist im Prinzip das Session Cookie, was sich ausgelesen hat. Ähm, Function
wahrscheinlich 126, das weiß nur Unity Media. Wahrscheinlich ist Function 126 der Ping,
Function 126 wird der Ping sein oder, oder ist Type der Ping? Wahrscheinlich ist Function
126 der Ping. Ähm, so Ping Size 64, nur Ping Intervall 1, so Session, so jetzt macht er
dann Post auf, auf XML, Setter XML, das ist anscheinend, das ist, das ist der Endpoint,
der nicht Passwort geschützt ist bei Unity Media, was auch schon wieder richtig krass
fail ist. Guck mal, ob ich nicht welche Subs verpasst hab, nicht. Nope. Ähm, ok, da macht
nichts Schlimmes auf jeden Fall. Das können wir, das können wir tatsächlich mal ausführen,
dann geh ich mal auf meine Linux-Kiste, geh ich mal auf meine Linux-Kiste, dann führen
wir das mal aus. Und gucken wir mal was mit meiner, ja, es gibt, gucken wir mal was mit
meiner Connectbox so los ist. Wow! Was mit meiner VM? Vergiss nicht die Firewall, warum?
Ich bin in meinem Internet, ich darf das. Sonst kannst du es ja nicht testen. Doch, kann
ich, von meinem internen Netz darf ich ja, ich darf ja hier auf die Fritzbox, äh, auf
die, auf die Connectbox. Äh, Moment, wo, wo war denn hier nochmal das komische Skript
hier da? Was hast du dann gesperrt? Na, dass man vom WLAN, dass man vom WLAN aus überhaupt
auf die Seite drauf kann. Ich habe jetzt, ich habe jetzt den Zugriff auf die Connectbox
von jeglichem Netzwerk aus gesperrt, außer von meinem internen Netzwerk. Ok, ähm, also
wir können das ohne Probleme Onstream ausführen, oder Leute? Wollen wir, komm wir führen das
Onstream aus, easy. Was muss man bei Command eigentlich angeben? Äh, ah, Command ist das,
was man angeht. Näh, ich mach da Echo 1 oder sowas. Es kann, es kann eigentlich, ich mach
Echo 1 oder irgendwas. Echo, einfach Echo gut ist. Ähm, was printet der denn? Nix, ok
dann. Also, dann probieren wir das mal aus. Bam. Also, zack. So, wie muss man den Kram
noch mal auf? Ich habe kein Python 3, natürlich habe ich Python 3. Fuck. Achso, das ist ja
Arschlinux, das ist ja, das ist ja dann woanders. Da, da, da. What? Was? Ist das Windows Zeilen
Ending? Kann das sein? Windows Zeilen Endung? Warum? Ah. Warum? Ja, ok, 1, 2, 0, 0.0 Echo.
Haha, anscheinend ist meine Connectbox noch, ähm, von wegen Unity Media, von wegen habt
das überall, überall ausgerollt, ja. Na gut, Command, Command Successful Send. Näh,
Moment mal, Moment mal, Moment mal, Command Successful Send, das heißt ja nur, dass dieser
Status Code hier ok ist. Ähm, wir müssen da jetzt irgendwas auslösen, was wir mitkriegen.
Äh, Reboot, das beknackt, ich kann doch nicht Rebooten, da ist das Stream weg. Wenn es
nicht gehen würde, naja, je nachdem was die gefixt haben, ja. Also wenn die gefixt haben,
dass man, ähm, dass man hier nicht ohne Passwort drauf zugreifen kann, dann, Moment, was haben,
was sagen die denn, was die gefixt haben? Ich mach jetzt kein Reboot, der könnte mir,
Chat, ey. Man könnte sich selbst anpingen, ja. Ich muss das aber auf dem Rechner machen,
durch das Mit, Mitkriege. Ich weiß, was wir machen, ich weiß, was wir machen, wir machen
jetzt Trick 17. Ice Freak, drei Monate, Dankeschön, Porgas. Die Firma wurde bereits auf 95% aller
Connectboxen, äh, installiert, erklärt hat der Unity-Media-Sprecher, haha, haha, ähm.
Achso, wisst ihr was wir mal ausprobieren können? Was passiert denn, wenn man hier so
fast eingibt? Successful Send, ok. Ähm. Auf diese Weise kann man das Routerbetriebssystem
dauerhaft zerstören. Also wir führen jetzt nichts drauf aus. Ähm, wir, was könnte man
dann mal ausprobieren? Können wir, ok, ok, lass mal überlegen. Ich könnte, ich könnte
meinen Router, ich könnte versuchen mein, ich, ich mach nen, ok, das können wir mal,
fuck, wie machen wir das? Ich könnte meinen Router sagen, er soll Pakete mitschneiden,
er soll Ping-Pakete an ihn mitschneiden von, von der IP von der Connectbox. Leute geht
mir nicht auf den Keks, ich mach jetzt garantiert kein Reboot. Ich fand die Web-OKD oben gut.
Ah, ok, was ist das denn, die Seite kenn ich gar nicht. Ach, interessant. Hm, will
ich aber nicht. Ich will nicht, dass meine, ich will nicht, dass meine Connectbox ähm,
nach außen zugreift. Ok, wie fun, wie funktioniert denn der Kram? Leute, ich reboote nicht. Ich
reboote nicht. Wie funktioniert denn das hier, just create? Was mach ich jetzt, einfach
nen Poster drauf? Post? Oder, oder was? Ach nee, das ist ja, ja gut, dann können wir,
dann können wir es probieren. Oh nein, Public IP leaked. MonkaS. Ähm, ja dann probieren
wir das doch von der, von der, von der Fritzbox aus. Also was muss man aufrufen? Das Ding hier?
Ah ja. Kann man, kann man das, kann man das so, jetzt übergeben überhaupt? Ah ja,
ok. Ok, mal probieren das, mal probieren das jetzt einfach mal aus. Ok, ok, ok, ok.
Hm. Scheint nicht mal zu funktionieren, ne? Weil man ja nicht weiß, ob da ein Curl drauf
ist. Äh, die drei Request waren von neben. Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt mal machen? Ja,
gut. Reboot. Wir probieren es jetzt aus. Scheiß drauf, ich reboot jetzt. Mal gucken, ob das
Stream klar weg ist. Ok, anscheinend, anscheinend ist meine Unity Media Box doch gefixt. Hä?
Wahrscheinlich ist es doch schon gefixt. Ah gut. Ok, ähm, jetzt wo ich, jetzt wo ich
eh schon, jetzt wo wir gerade dabei sind, jetzt wo wir gerade dabei sind. Ähm, jetzt
wo wir gerade dabei sind. Wobei, äh, das ist natürlich bescheuert von innen zu scannen.
Wir gucken mal, was da so für Ports auf sind auf der Connect Box. 80 und 5000. 5000 ist
UPNP und DNS. Ok. Ach ja, das andere können wir auch nochmal ausprobieren. Das andere
sind Dump. Wobei, ich weiß nicht, was da da alles dumpt, ne? Ähm, was passiert jetzt
eigentlich, wenn man das so scannt? Ich meine, das ergibt jetzt eigentlich nicht wirklich
so viel, was man anbieten kann. Was muss man angeben? Äh, P0? Ach ne, PN. Ok, das soll
man scannen. Ich, ich lock mich mal auf meiner. Ok. Ja, anscheinend, äh, auch wenn da, wenn,
wenn das kein richtiger Check von draußen ist, aber es geht wahrscheinlich aufs richtige
Interface, äh, anscheinend ist da tatsächlich nix auf, was ja für Unity Media spricht,
ne? Und irgend einer spammt die Webhooks hier voll. Ähm, genau, ich wollte das Skript ausprobieren,
Information Dump. DOS zu Unix. Und, ähm. Alter, w- warum geht man faunisch? Was wird
da naturlos? Ok, ähm. Mach euch mal kurz aus, ich hab echt keine Ahnung, was denn da
alles aussieht. Ich hab keinen Bock, dass du irgendwie Name oder so ausliest oder so,
man weiß ja nicht. Man weiß ja nie, ne? Keine Ahnung, was da, was da bei Unity Media alles
drinsteht. Es sollte nicht so sein, aber trotzdem Fail. Oh man, Python Modul hab ich nicht installiert.
Ok, mal gucken, was ich zeigen kann, klar. Aha.
Ok, was auch immer. Wollt ihr mal nen Browser Tab zum Absturz bringen, oder was, mit eurem
rumgespammer? Mach jetzt einfach mal nen Browser Tab zu. Doch, scheint gefixt zu sein, dass
das Information Dump Ding kann nix auslesen. Ich zeig's euch mal, ich mach mir den Bildschirm
an. Guck, das Information Dump Ding liest nix aus, außer dass es hier irgendwie Gedöns
ist, wo man, Exist Denied ist None. Aha. Ok, keine Ahnung. Anscheinend ist es tatsächlich
gefixt. Äh, wir können, wir können noch mal was ausprobieren. Ähm. Ok, jetzt haben wir
die, wie kann man bei seiner Connectbox gucken? Moment, wir gucken jetzt mal. Ich gucke jetzt
mal auf den zweiten Bildschirm, was ich für ne Firmware Version habe. Auf meiner, auf
meiner Connectbox. Kannste den Kram hier ausmachen, ich hab nämlich kein Bock, dass das
Ding irgendwelche Passwörter zwischenspeichert oder so. Ok, ich lock mich jetzt mal auf meiner
Connectbox ein. Ob ich das hier auch von hier dann machen kann. So, wo sieht man denn jetzt
die Firmware Version? Ja, Info. Ah, ich hab die gefixte Firmware Version. Ja, ich hab
die, ich hab die gefixte Firmware Version. Guck mal, das ist doch das, oder? 61218252P6NOSCH.
Ja, das hab ich drauf. Ok, Leute. Also da ist, oh fuck, ich hab mein Chat refreshed.
Ich hab jetzt, falls ich was übersehen hab, Leute, sag nochmal Bescheid. Also mit, mit,
mit, mit, meine Connectbox, heck so on, ist anscheinend nix. Payso, nee, Payaso, subscribe
Twitch Prime Poggers. Ok, da haben wir das jetzt nachgeguckt, also meine Connectbox ist
nicht mehr anfällig für den ganzen Kram. Gut, ähm, und außerdem ist das von außen
eh nur anfällig, wenn da irgendwas auf ist. Äh, Döner Bruder, ich bestell das meiste
Zeug bei AliExpress oder bei Banggood. Die Seite ist wirklich so. So, jetzt können wir
zum eigentlichen Thema kommen. Nämlich, ich muss gerade mal auf der anderen Seite refreshen.
So, also wir haben jetzt rausgekriegt, dass unsere Unity Media Box funktioniert. Was ich
allerdings immer noch sehr merkwürdig finde, dass die Unity Media Geschichte nicht einfach
von Axis Denied oder, oder, oder irgendwie, was ist es, 403, ähm, dass du nicht authenticated
bist, äh, liefert, wenn du diese, diese, diese Url aufrufst, warum es 200 sind, obwohl
es nicht funktioniert, ist ziemlich bescheuert. Warum es da überhaupt eine extra API für
gibt, ich weiß es nicht. Weil, gut, aber kommen wir mal zum eigentlichen Thema zurück.
Wie gesagt, die Kiste ist RIP, die macht nix mehr. Der Ping hat ja vielleicht funktioniert,
wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich hat der Ping funktioniert, allerdings finde ich es affig,
dass es überhaupt, äh, so eine Funktion gibt ohne Authentifizierung. Ich vermute mal,
das ist für Unity Media für irgendwelche Debug-Geschichten. Würde ich, würde ich jetzt
mal vermuten. Kennt, kennt jemand eine schöne Seite, wo man von außen ein Port scannen kann?
Sonst müsste ich mich jetzt auf, lass mal überlegen, oder ich verbinde mich, ja guck
weiter oben. Ich hab meinen Chat geflasht, keine Ahnung. Portchecker.co, machen wir doch
mal. Was, Portchecker.co, Punktco klingt schon wieder super vertrauenserweckend, ne.
Wer steckt denn da dahinter? Du hast es von, ah, du hast, du hast den IMAP gemacht, okay,
also ist alles zu von außen, ne. Ach man kann nur, ich will ja, ich will ja alles scannen.
Ich will ja nicht nur einen Port spielen, ich will alles, alles scannen. Was? Scan, Scamas,
ja. Okay, ne, also ich würd mal sagen, Unity Media hat's ordentlich gefixt, es ist nicht
mehr anfällig. Wofür nutzen Leute eigentlich VPN-Services, um nicht irgendwas illegales
Grauzone zu machen? Zum Beispiel, um asiatische MMOs zu spielen oder NA-Server bessere Verbindungen
hinzuhaben oder, was will der hier? Oh shit, ja. Oder, zum Beispiel, um DLCs zu laden vom
anderen Marketplace, um Battlefield früher spielen zu können, weil es in Korea immer
früher rauskommt. Ja genau, wollte ich auch jetzt sagen, wenn du in irgendeinem WLAN drinne
bist, was halt nicht dein eigenes WLAN ist, dann hast du die Verbindung auf jeden Fall
schon mal komplett verschlüsselt. Also, die häufigste Anwendung früher bei mir war tatsächlich,
also daheim, war tatsächlich, dass ich vom UK oder US Marketplace, Xbox, was laden konnte,
dass es nicht ging. Mit den Fiverr-Guys, die sind fertig. Die haben 10 von 11 abgesagt.
Das Ergebnis, das Ergebnis sackt. Der Einzige, der was geliefert hat, hat irgendwas programmiert,
was er selbst nicht gecheckt hat. Er hat, glaube ich, null gecheckt, was ich eigentlich
haben wollte. Naja, ist auch egal. Warum die abgesagt haben? Weil sie mehr zu den meisten,
der eine hatte keine Zeit, der andere wollte mehr Geld. Am besten war der Typ, der hat
halt reingeschrieben, ich programmiere für dich so sinngemäß eine komplette Anwendung
für irgendwie 11,20 Euro. Und dann hat er gesagt, ach nee, ich hätte gerne jetzt 780
Euro. Da hab ich auch gedacht, Scamas. Versuchst du es nur woanders oder selbst? Ich hab das
schon längst selbst gemacht, bevor ich überhaupt die Fiverr-Leute beauftragt habe. Ich weiß
nicht, ob ich den, hab ich den Fiverr-Code von dem Typ überhaupt hier? Hab ich, haben
wir uns den Fiverr-Code schonmal angeguckt? Ich, ich weiß nicht. Kannst du euch jetzt
nicht zeigen, ich hab das jetzt nicht hier. Da müsste ich mich jetzt erst ein paar Fiverr
anmelden. Ja ich weiß, ich wollte ein Video zu machen. Könnte ich eigentlich morgen
machen? Weil, ich mein, ich hab so heute ein Video hochgeladen, aber das war ja nie so
ein kurzes, kurzes Einschubsvideo, was ich heute hochgeladen hab. Ich mein, das interessiert
dir eigentlich ehrlich gesagt wahrscheinlich kaum jemand, wie es mit meinen Weisheitsszenen
so gewesen ist. Ich hab mal geguckt, ich war gerade mal auf dem Video drauf, mit den Weisheitsszenen
hier. Das guckt kein Mensch, interessiert wirklich kein, kann ich aber auch verstehen.
Ganz ehrlich, was interessiert die Leute, was mit meinen Weisheitsszenen ist. Oder was
mit meinen Weisheitsszenen war. Ähm, hast du den, ja ich hab den Fiverr-Typ bewertet.
Guckt euch das mal an. Nach ein paar Stunden, das ist übel slow für, für das was ich normalerweise
hab. Guckt keiner, liked keiner. Und ins sind 15 Leute, deabonniert, disabot, weil sie
dieses Thema eklig fanden. Hast du die China-Steckdosen-Lise in Apple HomeKit eingebunden? Nee. Ich hab gar
kein Apple HomeKit. Ich hab den Fiverr-Typ bewertet, ich hab ihm 5 Sterne gegeben. War
zwar schlecht, aber ich denk mir halt, ey, für den Apple und ein Ei, ähm, und außerdem
wollte ich denen da jetzt irgendwie keine Steine in den Weg legen. Ja, ich hab irgendwie
reingeschrieben, ähm, very good programming skills oder sowas. 5 Sterne. Ich hatte nur
zwei Weisheitsszenen, das geht offensichtlich, ja, weil ich hatte es. Was hast du alles
in der Taskbar? Was? Hier, die Tabs meinste. Oder hier oben. Oben, das ist, äh, disk space
free, RAM free oder RAM used, bin mir gar nicht sicher. Ähm, CPU Last, Load, IP, äh,
Bandbreite benutzt und Zeit. Dauerhaft Milchzeit, oh, das ist natürlich mal nice. Top eBayer,
gerne wieder. Ja, genau, das ist wie so eine eBay-Bewertung. Okay Leute, also, jetzt muss
ich noch mal zum eigentlichen Thema zurückkommen. Also, die Kiste ist RIP und ich hab jetzt
hier mal was zusammen gewurstet. Und zwar, ähm, das sind die Teile, die ich für das
10G nass gekauft hab. Ähm, das ist das billigste vom billigsten als Gehäuse. Also, das ist
wirklich, äh, 3-Head-Gehäuse. Das ist das billigste Gehäuse. Das ist ein, äh, Bitcoin-Mining-PCI-Express-Extender-Kabel. Das sieht, das sieht
genauso stabil aus, äh, das ist genauso stabil, wie es aussieht. Mit diesem Klebeband. Ja,
das ist da drunter schon gelötet. Das ist da drunter schon gelötet, aber sie haben
halt irgendwie noch ein paar Klebeband drüber gemacht. Wie soll ich einen Raspberry Pi am
besten konfigurieren, um die Ubiquiti UniFi-Admin-Oberfläche drauf laufen zu lassen? Macht das Sinn? Ja,
macht viel Sinn. Gar nicht großartig. Einfach, einfach starten drauf, um gut ist. Das einfachste
dürfte wahrscheinlich sein, das offizielle, das offizielle, äh, was ist das? Das offizielle
Docker-Image dürfte wahrscheinlich am einfachsten sein. Oder, ich glaub, es gibt auch, es gibt
auch einen Snap. Gibt's einen Snap? Oder, genau, oder das Debian-Repo? Kein Snap. Okay,
ja, dann nimm das offizielle Debian-Repo. Oder, oder nimm das offizielle Docker-Repo
von, also die offizielle Docker-Image von denen. Das kannst du machen wie willst, aber das
macht sehr viel Sinn, das auf dem Raspberry laufen zu lassen, ja. Ich bin ja immer noch
keiner Fan da, richtig von, weil ich hab am liebsten, wenn die Web, wenn die Access-Points
eine ordentliche Web-Interface haben, hier zum Beispiel, das Mikro-Tick-Ding, das ist
halt sehr praktisch, wenn man das verwalten kann über das Web-Interface. Ich versteh'
es, dass dieses Unified-Zeug cool ist, wenn man einfach 150 Access-Points und Geräte
verwaltet. Ja, das ist schon nice. Nun ja, zurück zu der Kiste. Also, was ihr da gerade
seht, ist, wie gesagt, ziemlich zusammengewurstet. Das sind zwei 10 Gigabit Netzwerkkarten,
davon brauch' ich aber nur eine. Die eine steckt mit so einem Bitcoin, mit so einem
Bitcoin-Kabel, Bitcoin-Mining-Kabel, PCI-Express, im Slot drinnen, weil ich hab' keine Möglichkeit,
die anderweitig ins Gehäuse reinzubringen, weil das Gehäuse hat zwar hier zwei PCI-Express-Slots,
allerdings sind die Karten zu lang, als dass sie hinter den Wechselrahmen von den Festplatten
passen würden. Das hier vorne ist ein, das ist ein Wechsel, wie nennt man das eigentlich
offiziell? So ein Hotswap. Wie heißt denn das? Backplane? Wie nennt man so ein Ding offiziell?
Backplane ist hinten das Ding, was drauf ist. Wechselrahmen, ja. Wie heißt denn so ein
Ding eigentlich, wie heißt denn das eigentlich korrekt? Swap. Ja, so ein Ding halt, ne. So
ein Ding ist da vorne drin. So ein Wechselrahmen, da kann man vorne zwei Festplatten rein machen,
reinschieben. Die sind Hotswap-fähig und kann man im laufenden Betrieb tauschen. Und ansonsten
ist da nix weiter drinnen. Da ist nen ITX-Mini-Mainboard drinnen mit nem passiv gekühlten 4-Cash-Mini,
4-Kern, ähm, was ist das? Wie nennt sich das? Pentium-Silber oder so? Das ist im Prinzip
so ein Atom-Ding. 4-Kern, Jiminy-Lake-Ding, also nix, nix sonderlich tolles. Und, 2x8
Gigabyte RAM. Das ist kein Atom, also die heißen offiziell nicht Atom, aber es ist
ein Abkömmling vom Atom. Atom. Genau, da hat man zwei SATA-Ports, USB 3 und nochmal hier
irgendwo USB 2. Da hab ich auch die passenden Header noch irgendwo rumfliegen. Und hier
oben ist nen Direct-Attached 10 Gigabit Kupferkabel. So. Das heißt, wir könnten das jetzt mal anschließen
und gucken, ob wir das zum Laufen kriegen. Ich bin mir allerdings noch nicht so ganz sicher,
wie wir's machen wollen. Vorausgesetzt, man lässt es nicht drauffallen, ja das stimmt.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, wie hast du das mit der USB geschafft? Naja, die USB steht hier in
der Ecke. Ich hab's ja vorhin schon erklärt. Die USB steht hier in der Ecke. Hier vorne
kannst du deine Füße hinstellen. Weil du nicht richtig reinlaufen kannst, du den Raum
vor dem ganzen Zeug, was da drinnen liegt beim Umräumen. Und da hab ich das Ding halt
angehoben und alles runtergerutscht und hat drauf gefallen. Grip. Halt. Fail. Dazu kommt,
dass es das billigste Board von allen ist, die ich hatte. Hat 4 Gigabyte RAM drinnen,
nur ein Dual-Core. Also um die Hardware ist es jetzt nicht so wirklich schade. Das kostet
auch nicht die Welt, das Board. Also es ist nicht so, dass es ein super finanzieller
Verlust ist und außerdem komm ich auch mal 1-2 Tage aus, ohne dass meine Heimautomatisierung
daheim läuft, ja. Das funktioniert schon. MasterDomeTV abonniert schon 2 Monate aktuell
im ersten fortlaufenden Monat. Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, Poggers. HiiQChat heute. Kiyokun,
Moin, da ist er. QChat ist am Start. So viele Fragen im Chat, ich komm ja überhaupt nicht
dazu irgendwas zu machen. Wie hast du eigentlich Programmieren gelernt? Selber beigebracht
oder Schulung ITC selber beigebracht? Ich hab in meinem Leben nicht eine Schulung in
dieser Richtung gemacht. Ich finde auch, man lernt das am besten in Eigenregie. Weil da
hat man seine Ruhe und ich sag's ja immer, dass Programmieren eine kreative Tätigkeit
ist. Ja, das verstehen viele BWL-Management-Leute nicht. Aber Programmieren ist was Kreatives
und kreativ kann man schlecht auf Kommando sein. Hot Swap HDD-Mount, ja so könnte man
das Ganze nennen. Der Keeper XY, ja ja, nächste Woche bin ich wieder da. Nächste Woche bin
ich wieder da. Da sieht man sich, ja. Nächste Woche bin ich wieder da. Genau, dann wussten
wir das Ding jetzt mal zusammen. Flo96 sagt, dann ist nicht das 2000 Euro Mainboard von
einem Server kaputt gegangen. Nein, nein, nein, Gott sei Dank nicht. Der steht immer
noch da, wo er auch in diesem Video stand. Nämlich oben auf dem Rack drauf. Also da
oben, man sieht ihn nicht. Da oben auf dem Rack drauf, in seiner 4-E-Kiste. Da hätte
auch ohne Probleme was drauffallen können und im Ding wäre nix passiert. Tim Weipel,
ne, Wüble, wie auch immer. Du musst das noch mal schreiben, ich hab Chat refreshed,
ich seh nix mehr. So, also, da müssen wir mal als Vorbereitung mal eine Sache machen,
das was meine Lieblingsbeschäftigung. Einmal nen Ubuntu Server runterladen. Ich bin übrigens
noch nicht ganz, ich bin noch ein bisschen unentschlossen, wie wir das Ganze anschließen,
weil das Ding hat ja nur, wie ihr ja hier seht, das Ding hat ja nur 2 SATA Ports, ne.
Das heißt entweder, achso, für die Systemplatte hab ich ne 2 TB Samsung SSD. Also das wird
ja wie gesagt nicht nur Heimautomatisierung. Wenn das Ding schon ne 10 Gigabit Karte drin
hat, dann will ich da auch ordentlich, ich kann schon mal ne Backup gleich draufschieben,
weil das Heimautomatisierungszeug verbraucht 5% CPU Last, das braucht nix, ja. Und ich
hab ja hier nur 2 SATA Ports. Das heißt, entweder nehm ich die 2 SATA Ports für 2 Platten hier
vorne, dass ich da auch n bisschen Storage rein krieg und die Systemplatte, oder besser
gesagt die SATA SSD mach ich hier intern irgendwo ins Gehäuse, ist ja genug Platz,
die müsste ich dann allerdings per USB anschließen. Ich hab hier noch nen, hier, ich hab hier
noch so nen, so nen USB 3, oder ne, sorry, USB 3.2 Generation 1 Adapter, vielleicht ist
es auch ein USB 3.2 Generation 2 Adapter, allerdings ist es garantiert kein USB 3.2 Generation
2x2 Adapter, so viel kann ich dazu sagen, ja. Ich hoffe, ihr habt das jetzt alles verstanden.
Ähm, für die, für die SSD. Und ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie ich den ganzen Kram
anschließe. Spiegelst du die Platten? Ja, das hab ich vor, also wenn ich, wenn ich das
so mache, also am liebsten würde ich ja, ähm, äh, Tim, ein paar Minuten musst du
schon warten, ähm, wenn ich nämlich hier vorne die 2 Platten rein kriege, dann kann
ich dann nämlich wenigstens in Rate 1 drauf machen. Ich mein, ich hab zwar gesagt, ich
will es so einfach wie möglich machen, aber ich hab mir überlegt, in Rate 1 wäre zumindest
mal sofern ganz nice, dass, ähm, die Sache dann halt nicht im laufenden Betrieb einmal
nicht mehr da ist. Da muss ich mal gucken. Aber, das erste, was wir ausprobieren, wir,
wir machen das gar nicht fertig, also nicht komplett fertig, das erste, was ich mal ausprobieren
will ist, ob das Ding überhaupt booten würde von, ähm, mit diesem USB Adapter, ob das
überhaupt funktioniert. Gibt es Seiten, die du empfiehlst, um, äh, programmieren zu
lernen? Ja, ich würde gucken, ob es kostenlose Bücher gibt. Bücher finde ich, ist immer
noch, auch im Jahr 2019 ein ordentlich geschriebenes Buch zu einer Programmiersprache, ist immer
noch super, ähm, einfach weil es, äh, wie soll man sagen, weil das eine gewisse Qualität
ist, ja. Ist nicht verkehrt. Ist es eigentlich gut, wenn ich 3 Millionen Domains blockiere?
Kommt auf die Domains an. So, also, was hat der Tim gefragt? Weißt du zufällig, warum
ein Game, wenn man nicht im Vollwind spielt, sich denkt, auf 60 FPS capped, äh, spielt
sich direkt auf 60 FPS capped, sobald man ein Streaming-Programm startet. Hm. Warum
ein Game, was man nicht im Voll, also, also quasi im Window-Mode oder im Borderless-Window-Mode
spielt, sich direkt auf 60 FPS capped? Hast du dein, hast du dein Windows eingestellt irgendwie
auf, auf 60 Hz oder so? Und, und wie ist es im Vollscreen? Das Game geht nicht im Vollscreen.
Das Game ja generell nen, vielleicht ist das Game ja generell nen 60 FPS capped. Wie ist,
kannst du mal Viewsync ausschalten? Aber ansonsten würde ich eben Internet mal suchen. USB ist
echt langsam. Ja, das ist aber nicht schlimm für, also für die Systemplatte wäre das
nicht so wild. Ähm, ich hab hier auch noch, ich hab noch ne 1TB, ähm, ne 1TB NVMe SSD
und ich hab nen USB auf NVMe, NVMe Adapter. Könnte man auch reinmachen. Aber ich will
mal gucken, das können wir zumindest jetzt im Stream mal ausprobieren, einfach mal prinzipiell
gucken, ob das denn überhaupt von USB booten würde. Das probieren wir mal aus. Ähm, für
irgendwie großartige, äh, wir machen das komplett fertig, hab ich zu viel gesidetrackt,
aber so ein bisschen was ausprobieren können wir noch. Okay, wir, wir downloaden uns jetzt
erstmal aktuelles Yu, Yu, wait, wie, wie muss man das nochmal aussprechen? Ubuntu ist ja
falsch, ne? Ja, Ubuntu, Ja, Ja, Ubuntu, Ubuntu, Ubuntu, oder? Ubuntu, Ubuntu ist für die,
für die coolen Leute, ja, verstehe. Äh, ich will nicht Ubuntu Desktop downloaden,
so aber. Und ich will nicht auch das, ich will auch nicht das downloaden, sondern ich
will den Alternate Installer, weil ja, wo ist der Alternate Installer? Ähm, weil ja
der offizielle Ubuntu Server Installer mittlerweile total kaputt ist. Den da will ich haben. Ubuntu
für IBM Z, oh je, ja, ja. Schlimm, schlimm. Wow, guckt euch das mal an hier, hä? Hä?
Flutscht. Hi Noob, Subscribed, Stufe 1, Dankeschön, Poggers, ich weiß nicht, ob ich schon vorgelesen
habe, aber, äh, Moment, das ist noch nicht mal, du bist ja noch nicht mal Prime. Wer guckt?
Jetzt Flutscht, jetzt haben sie mich gedrosselt. Drossel, null. Omega Drossel. Ok, zack, da
ist es, äh, man muss mal einen USB-Stick rein, rein eliminieren in den USB-Port, oder
was sagt man da heute eigentlich heutzutage so auf, auf YouTube, ja, wenn man Kommentare
schreibt, also früher hat man ja Kommentare eliminiert, äh, Leute mein, mein Chat ist
weg, wo muss man? Ich weiß nicht, wie ich mein Chat wieder einblende, MonkaS, ich kann
mein Chat nicht mal einblenden. Ah, jetzt. Ok.
Ok, jetzt, jetzt geht's wieder. Ich weiß nicht, was das gerade gewesen ist, keine Ahnung.
Ähm, ja, wie nennt man das denn? Früher hat man, früher hat man Sachen in die Kommentare
eliminiert, ja, wie, was macht man heute? Also, einzige, was ich noch weiß, ist, man
macht auch kein De-Abo, man macht nur noch Dis-Abo, ist doch ganz klar. Also, wir machen
erstmal hier blim-blim, blim-blim, connect to virtual-Maschinen, und jetzt flashen wir
mal ne Runde, Ubuntu. Ja, Ubuntu. Warum kann man nicht einfach wie jeder normale Mensch
Ubuntu sagen? Wahrscheinlich sagen die Südafrikaner auch Ubuntu. Was sprechen die Südafrikaner,
Afrikaans oder so? Afrikaans, oh. Pronounciation, ich kann das nicht schreiben. Das Ubuntu
still exists in South Africa. Ok. Äh. Ja, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kriegen wir's erklärt.
Nelson Mandela himself spricht Ubuntu aus. Ok. Ubuntu, Ubuntu, die sagen Ubuntu, die
sagen nicht Ubuntu, hört's euch an. Alles Kamaas, stimmt hinten und vorne nicht. Ubuntu.
Was? Ich will's, ich will's von ihm hören. Ubuntu
Leute, nicht Ubuntu. Ubuntu. Also, wir können ruhig, wenn sogar Nelson Mandela himself sagt,
es ist Ubuntu, warum ist das Ubuntu-Logo in dem Video? Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Warum ist das Ubuntu-Logo in dem Video? Das ist echt keine Ahnung. Es ergibt eigentlich
überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass das Ubuntu-Logo da drinnen ist, ne? Es ergibt wirklich überhaupt
keinen Sinn. Egal, das ist bescheuert eigentlich. Warum ist das Ubuntu? Ich weiß es nicht.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es irgendein Ubuntu-Fan ist. Ok, also, wir, wow, ja, ja. Wir flashen
das Ganze jetzt mal. Was bedeutet das dann abgesehen vom Betriebssystem? Ich glaube,
und das kann jetzt vollkommen verkehrt sein. Ich glaube, das heißt sowas wie, sowas wie
für Verbundenheit oder irgendwie sowas. Irgendwie sowas muss das heißen, dass man sich verbunden
fühlt oder so. Gucken wir mal. Ubuntu heißt Humanity, ok. Ubuntu. I am because we are.
Na, das ist doch Humanity towards, na, das hat schon was mit Verbundenheit zu tun, ja.
Ja, guck hier. Universal Bond of Sharing that connects all, da war das doch mit Verbundenheit,
was ich gesagt hab, eigentlich gar nicht so weit weg, oder? Deswegen, ich finde, das
ist eine der besten Linux-Distributionen-Namen überhaupt, ja, von der Bedeutung her. Das
ist wirklich was Kreatives, ja, kommt ja auch aus Südafrika. Select Image. So, wir installieren
von Downloads Ubuntu Server. Da auf dem USB Stick war schonmal ein Ubuntu drauf. Verbundhut,
genau. Wartet mal ab. Wenn Google Stadia kommt, dann gibt es dann irgendwo Stadia OS oder
sowas. Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass das massiv geil wäre, wenn die ihr Stadia Zeug veröffentlichen,
was sie nicht machen werden, aber was cool wäre, das würde auf einen Schlag sau viele
Games auf Linux lauffähig machen, und zwar tip top, werden sie aber nicht machen. Wann
kommt eine Founders Edition aus, eine gute Frage. Und wann sollen die Dinger dann verschickt
werden? Oktober, November, ja, dann dauert es noch. Ok, so, USB Stick ist gemacht. Hast
du schonmal gesagt, was du vom Raspberry Pi mit P-Hole hältst? Ja, ich finde es ein super
Projekt, allerdings mittlerweile nicht mehr so wirksam, wie das früher noch gewesen ist.
Beispielsweise auf Twitch und YouTube, und deshalb habe ich ja live im Stream demonstriert,
ich weiß nicht mehr, ich glaube auf YouTube hatten wir sonst eingeguckt, funktioniert
das nicht mehr. Oder war es auf Twitch? Ich glaube YouTube. Wir hatten es uns gleich angeguckt,
es funktioniert auf YouTube nicht mehr. Und es liegt daran, vielleicht haben sie auch irgendwas
gefunden, dass es jetzt wieder funktioniert, aber es funktioniert nicht, weil die Jungs
von YouTube, ach auf Twitch geht es nicht, ich weiß nicht mehr, was wir ausbreiten,
wir haben es nachgestellt, wir haben es nachgestellt auf dem, also mit P-Hole an, und ich weiß
nicht, ob wir es, zumindest war die Werbung auf der Seite nicht weg, die wir ausprobiert
haben, und das liegt daran, weil die Streams und die Werbung von der gleichen Domain kommt,
und dementsprechend kann P-Hole gar nicht das plocken, weil sollte P-Hole die Domain
plocken, wäre auch keinerlei Content, den man sehen möchte von der Seite mehr sichtbar.
Also das ist natürlich ein cleverer Schachzug von Amazon und Google in dem Fall. Das einzige,
was man dagegen machen kann, ist eben Software verwenden, die versteht, was wie die Seite
aufgebaut ist, also wie zum Beispiel Uplock Origin als Browser Addon, oder aber, und da
bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob irgendjemand sowas schon mal gebaut hat, einen Proxy Server.
Ein Proxy Server müsste auch gehen, ich habe aber keine Ahnung, ob es einen Adblock Proxy
gibt.
Hattest du das nicht auf deinem Staubsauger installiert?
Ne, auf dem Staubsauger habe ich mein Versand, mein.NET Core Versandtracker mal installiert
und war überrascht, dass es funktioniert. So Leute, also ich teste jetzt mal, ob der
von USB überhaupt booten könnte. Muss ich erstmal mein USB Verlängerung und mein USB
Adapter aufmachen. Das ist ein richtig schöner billig China USB 3 auf SATA inklusive Strom
und so. Probieren wir mal aus.
So, jetzt habe ich das mal angestöpselt. So, was ich jetzt machen muss ist, ich muss
euch mal anschließen an die Kiste. Ich lege euch mal kurz neben hin und schließe den Kram
an und wir gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Ah, jetzt. Warum hat denn das so ewig gedauert?
Psygnum 420, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, Poggers. S-Rock, ja. Vlogs HD resubscribed, auch Poggers.
Dankeschön für die Subs. Ok, S-Rock am Start. So, ok, ich stöpsel jetzt mal die USB Platte
an und gucke. Da ist nämlich schon was drauf installiert, vielleicht brauchen wir den USB-Stick
gar nicht. Gucken wir mal, ob der bootet mit USB.
Fuck. Ich habe es gerade geschafft, das USB-Kabel falsch rum reinzustecken und das hat funktioniert.
Das sollte eigentlich bei USB überhaupt nicht gehen.
Mal gucken, ob der bootet von der USB-Platte. Was ist jetzt los?
Ich glaube mal, GameCapture spackt. Max, hast du schon mal einen ausversehenden USB-Stick
in den R845-Port gesteckt? Kann sein. Ey! Der bootet von USB. Das gefällt mir. Achso,
ich habe kein Netzwerk-Kabel dran, warte mal kurz.
So, ist jetzt gestartet. Ja, Pogu. Pogu heißt da die Kiste. Geh mal gucken.
Sag mal, SSH. Okay, was auch immer. Yes. Achso. Ey! Nice, der bootet von USB. So, dann gucken
wir mal, wie schnell der ist von USB. Also, das ist eine 2TB Samsung QEVO 80068. Ach, du.
Wir gucken mal, was das Ding theoretisch kriegen müsste. Ja, Microsoft Fanboy. Ne, ne, Quatsch.
Performance. Was taugt denn da? Der SSSD-Benchmark, genau. Read-Write. Write 500 MB, Read 530 MB.
Achso, ne, meint es nicht meine Kiste. So, jetzt gucken wir mal. Dd, probieren wir mal
aus. Also, df. Wir haben hier auch nutzbar 1TB SSSD. Oh, wie ging das nochmal? HD? Palm
minus L? Ne, fuck, minus L. List? Ne, wie ging das nochmal, dass man sich Informationen
zum Hersteller anzeigen lassen kann? Das kann ich mir mal aus dem Kopf nicht merken.
War das HD Palm? Minus i war es, weil die sich ja nicht einig werden. Minus krosi? Jaa.
Ok. Also, was ist es? Es ist eine Samsung SSSD 63 QEVO, 2TB, Seriennummer, Blah, was auch
immer. Und es ist natürlich smart, ganz wichtig, sehr smart. Ok, gucken wir mal. Dd. So, also,
wir kopieren jetzt einfach mal was. Wir kopieren jetzt einfach mal, wir kopieren jetzt einfach
mal Nullen auf die SSSD. Clock Size, keine Ahnung, 4096, Count, ne, wie war das Status?
Gleich, Progress, Count, keine Ahnung. Ne, wir machen einfach ohne Count, wir schreiben
einfach ohne Pause. Ok, also wir kriegen Schreiben, Schreiben kriegen wir ungefähr, was ist da
los? Das ist aber nicht gut. Ich mein sequenziell Nullen schreiben sollte eigentlich flutschen,
ne? Aber nicht so schnell. SSD, das könnte, ne, das könnte auch an diesem komischen USB-Adapter
liegen, ne? Das weiß man dann nicht. FData Sync, wie war das nochmal? Weil aktuell ist
es so, dass die ganzen Caches und so, hallo? Die QEVO Dinger kracken doch ab, keine Ahnung,
das will ich mal ausprobieren. Ok, jetzt, jetzt geht nichts in den Cache, jetzt schreibt
das jetzt, jetzt muss es quasi, dass er das nächste, dass er den nächsten Block schreibt,
muss der quasi auf der Platte sein oder so. So, gucken wir mal. Ja, die ersten paar MBs
sind schnell und danach bricht das, bricht das ein. Aber gut, das liegt bestimmt an der
Technik an sich, ne? Jaja, der hat wahrscheinlich einen Cache und danach wird es langsamer.
I copy tests. Ah, guck mal hier. 78, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, das bricht, der Cache 78 Gigabyte,
nicht mal ansatzweise hier. Scamas SSD, Alter. Was denn das? Ich meine, wie gesagt, das könnte
auch an diesem USB Adapter liegen, aber glaube ich nicht, weil dann würde es am Anfang nicht
schnell gehen, weil dem Adapter ist es doch scheiß egal, ob die SSD cached oder nicht,
der Adapter schiebt drüber. Und dieser 2 Euro Adapter hat garantiert keinen eigenen Cache
oder sowas. Das deckt sich ja ungefähr, wenn der Cache voll ist, wenn der Cache voll ist,
dann droppt es auf ungefähr 140. Das kommt ja hin, das kommt ja hin. Okay, jetzt lesen
wir mal, jetzt lesen wir mal. Gucken wir mal, wie schnell wir lesen sind. Kannste mal abbrechen?
Jetzt gucken wir mal, wie schnell wir lesen von der SSD. Und wie gesagt, das ist der simpelste,
der simpelste Test, was man überhaupt machen kann bei einer SSD. Einfach sequenziell Nullen
drauf schreiben. Okay, jetzt lesen wir von Image Bin und schmeißen alles, was wir lesen,
wieder weg. Das kommt jetzt aus dem Cache, ne? Also das kommt nicht mal aus dem Cache
von der Platte, das kommt aus meinem Linux Betrieb, also aus meinem RAM wahrscheinlich.
Wie war das nochmal mit Caches droppen? Nicht Cache, Caches. Ging das nochmal? Ja,
so. So. Okay, alles. Wir clearen alles. Oh. Tipp. Meine VM ist gerade abgekackt oder auch
nicht. Okay, Cache ist weg. Bäm. Das ist nicht meine, das ist die VM, das ist nicht
der Host, der hier irgendwie rumspackt, ne? Der Host langweilt sich. Der macht nichts,
der uploadet den Stream. Okay, jetzt reden wir nochmal. Was ist denn das? Okay, ich schließe
die jetzt nochmal per SATA an. Leute, ich schließe das nochmal per SATA an. Ich schließe,
naja, bei SSDs ist es ja nicht die sequenzielle Datenrate, das einzig gute, sondern auch
die Zugriffszeiten, ja? Okay, das ist lahm. Wir schließen das Ganze nochmal per SATA an
und gucken, ob es da irgendwie schneller ist. Ähm, warum haben wir eigentlich keinen Output?
Achso, weil ich gerade Power aufgemacht hab. Big Brain. Okay, ähm, ich schließe das,
wo hab ich ein SATA-Kabel? Ich schließe das jetzt mal per SATA an. Sagt mal Leute, es
ist scheißegal, welches SATA-Kabel, oder? SATA-Kabel ist SATA-Kabel. Gibt's nix, worauf
man achten muss, wie bei USB, oder? Ich nehm einfach irgendein SATA-Kabel, was bei mir
rumliegt. Ähm, ah, okay.
Was sollt ihr wieder angehen?
Und, startet's? Hey, es startet. One moment, please. Das war jetzt die Auflösungswechsel,
das war zu viel für Elgato. Okay, das startet. Dann können wir uns dienungstechnisch wieder
verbinden. Der sollt ja eigentlich wieder da sein. Da isser. So, und jetzt schauen wir
mal. Ähm, jetzt schauen wir mal, was die SSD über SATA sagt. Ahhhh. Ja, das sieht
doch schon mal besser aus. Okay, der USB-Adapter ist scheiße. Um's mal auf den Punkt zu bringen.
Der USB-Adapter ist kacke. Okay. Dann schreiben wir jetzt noch mal drauf und gucken, wie sich
das da auswirkt. So bei 4-5 MB ist er getroppt, ne. So jetzt, jetzt ist er normalerweise langsamer
geworden. Okay, das müsst ihr mir jetzt mal erklären. Was hat denn der USB-Adapter da
für eine Auswirkung drauf, dass der nach ner Weile einbricht, wenn er von Anfang an
zu langsam gewesen wäre. Das hätt ich verstanden. Aber der USB-Adapter, also mit USB-Adapter
ging es die ersten Adapter zu warm. Äh. Der Adapter zu warm. Echt? Fehl des RGB, ja,
das wird's sein. Der Adapter. USB-Controller auf'm Board. Ja, das klingt doch irgendwie
logischer. Okay, doch nicht Scamas. Also passt alles. Wir haben 346 MB schreiben und 540
MB lesen. Okay, der USB-Adapter. Vielleicht ist aber auch einfach, doch das wird wahrscheinlich
mit dem USB-Controller zusammenhängen. Wahrscheinlich ist es einfach Müll. Aber reicht ja. Ich brauch
das USB ja eigentlich auch gar nicht großartig. Ich brauch das nur für ein paar Geräte heimautomatisierungstechnisch
und für die reichen wahrscheinlich ein paar Kilobyte. Und für ne Backup-Festplatte, die
dran hängt per USB. Aber da reicht das auch. Wie zur Hölle bekommt man die Idee dazu so
schnell zu schreiben? Naja, du brauchst ne SSD. Passt mal auf, willst du mal sehen, wie schnell
die Idee schreiben kann? Jetzt kommt der Big Brain Move, Leute. Pass mal auf. Guck dir
das mal an. Der liest Nullen und birft sie gleich wieder weg. Und das Ganze zwar mit
1,1 GB pro Sekunde. Also quasi von nichts von der CPU in den
Müll quasi. Ok, das flutscht ordentlich. Leider bringt mir das aber nichts. Also SSD-Performance
ist ganz ok. 350 schreiben, 550 lesen. Dann lass ich das mit dem USB-Adapter doch sein.
Und dann werde ich, sag mal, irgendwie knackst das bei euch auch so ein bisschen, die Musik?
Das liegt aber an dem Stream, ne? Das knackst auch. Das könnte auch irgendwie an OBS oder
AVM oder so liegen. Keine Ahnung. Das knackst alles ein bisschen. Monka Knackzor. Ah, das
ist ne, ne Elgato-Geschichte, das Knacksen. Aha, da war irgendwie der Sound, der Sound
angeschaltet, warum auch immer. Richtig feifert. Joa, also das ist ordentlich schnell. Gut,
das heißt, USB suckt mega. Das heißt, wir machen das anders. Ich mach die SSD in den
Wechselrahmen rein und ich mach ne 12TB HDD in den zweiten Slot rein. Backup-Platte kommt
per USB dran und gut ist. Easy. Die Sache ist dann bloß die, ne? Lohnt sich dann die
10Gigabit-Karte überhaupt. Was ist kaputt? Ich hab mein USB auf mein, auf das Mainboard
geschmissen, wo mein Heimautomatisierungszeug drauf läuft. Und bei der Gelegenheit hab
ich mir gedacht, also das ist komplett verreckt. Die alte USB wohlgemerkt auch noch. Und bei
der Gelegenheit hab ich mir gedacht, ich könnte jetzt mal probieren, anstatt einfach ein anderes
Mainboard zu nehmen und die alte Festplatte wieder dran zu hängen, mal gucken, ob das
mit dem 10Gigabit-Nasen nicht noch was wird. Weil ich hab die Hardware ja da. Das sieht
ein bisschen unordentlich aus. Ja, ich bin ja auch grad am Umräumen. Also Sinn und Zweck
war ja eigentlich, dass ich hier oben an die Wand noch Regale mache und ich wollte den
ganzen Scheiß, den ich nicht mehr brauche, und der einfach so rumliegt, ordentlich einbauen
in Gehäuse und die alten Kabel und den ganzen alten Müll, das Kabel brauch ich nicht mehr,
das alt, alles rausmachen und dabei ist mir halt, als ich die USB rausräumen wollte,
ist mir die USB aufs Mainboard gefallen. Was verbindet dieses fette Flachbandkabel?
Das ist ein Bitcoin-Mining-Kabel, also so ein Bitcoin, kannst du dir bei jedem x-beliebigen
Bitcoin-Mining-Shop kaufen, um Grafikkarten PCI-Express quasi überall im Gehäuse installieren
zu können. Und nachdem dieses Gehäuse keinen Ausgang hat für PCI-Express, wo die Karte
reinpasst, hab ich so die 10Gigabit-Karte angeschlossen. Das funktioniert auch. Das
sieht halt ultra billig aus hier, ne? Das sieht halt ultra billig aus. Ich bin gerade
am überlegen, brauche ich die 10Gigabit-Karte, aber ich wäre ja schon dafür irgendwo, ne?
Das ist eine PCI-Express-Verlängerung, genau. Ich wäre ja schon dafür, weil ich meine,
zumindest, zumindest von der SSD kann ich ordentlich lesen. 500MB die Sekunde, 550MB die Sekunde.
Ich mein, das ist ein, na, kein Drittel, nicht wirklich ein Drittel. Bisschen mehr
als ein Drittel. Also 1250MB sollten Max sein für 10Gigabit, wirst du allerdings selten
erreichen, sag mal 1000. Sag mal die Hälfte. Es ist ungefähr die Hälfte, ungefähr die
Hälfte von dem, was man über 10Gigabit rüber kriegen könnte, was die SSD im Lesen packt.
Du hast einen Bug in meinem Tracker gefunden. Mein Tracker ist wahrscheinlich voller Bugs.
Ich hab so viel Zeug hier, ich müsste so viele Sachen machen. Wir müssen den Tracker fertig
machen, wir müssen das Memetool fertig machen, ich muss hier meine Heimautomatisierungskiste
wieder zum Laufen bringen, ich muss Videos machen dabei, da muss ich noch absolut, also
ich weiß nicht, wo ich mit meiner ganzen Zeit, ich bräuchte eigentlich mal ein Jahr, wo
ich nicht arbeiten gehe, dass ich alles auf die Reihe kriege, was ich machen will. Ja,
wenn du Raid 1 hast, aber ich hab ja kein Raid 1, weil ich hab nur zwei Festplatten,
ich zeig euch mal das Gehäuse. Das ist das billigste, das billigste Gehäuse, was ich
finden konnte, was 19 Zoll ist und 2, 2 Hotswap-Dinger mitliefert. Das da, 62 Euro. Das ist das.
Zwei SSDs, ja zwei SSDs wäre noch ne Variante. Zwei SSDs wäre tatsächlich noch ne Variante,
wobei mir das Problem ist halt, dann hab ich bloß zwei Terabyte. Und zwei Terabyte sind
mir ein bisschen wenig. Ich mein, ich könnte, ich könnte dann die Platten anschließend
noch per, per USB. Oder aber, was wir ausprobieren. Oh Leute, wisst ihr was wir jetzt ausprobieren?
Das wollt ich schon die ganze Zeit ausprobieren. Und zwar, ich hab mir was bei Amazon bestellt.
Und zwar hab ich mir bei Amazon einen, ich muss es, ich muss es, ich hab nen SATA Port
Multiplier bestellt. Und zwar nen SATA 3 Port Multiplier. Da kann man aus einem SATA
5 SATA Ports machen. Und angeblich unterstützt dieses Mainboard SATA Port Multiplier. Ich
mein, von der Bandbreite her ist natürlich trotzdem nicht mehr drinnen, wie über einen
SATA Port geht. Aber bei normalen Magnetplatten reicht ungefähr ein SATA 3 Port für zwei
Platten. Gibt's bei Wish auch. Ja, aber Wish sackt. Und Amazon nicht. Ja, ich glaube, einen
davon hab ich mir bestellt. Ähm, ich hab mir ja schon ne Ladung davor bestellt bei AliExpress.
Ich hab noch ein paar alte über AliExpress. Ähm, da gibt's nämlich tausende davon. So
und ich weiß nur nicht, wo ich den Kram hingeschmissen hab, müsste ich jetzt mir im Regal gucken.
So und was man damit machen kann ist, wir schließen, das probieren wir jetzt echt aus.
Ich brauch dazu aber, ich brauch dazu aber SSDs. Ich brauch dazu SSDs. Okay Leute, wir
müssen jetzt, wir müssen es jetzt mal suchen. Wir müssen erst mal dieses komische Gerät
finden. Was? Dann verlierst du bestimmt Smart- oder Raid-Möglichkeiten. Na ja, Raid-Möglichkeiten
verlier ich damit nicht. Ähm, Raid-Möglichkeiten verlier ich mit. Raid würd ich eh mit ZFS
machen. So heißt das kein Ding. Posthallzahlen, oh nein! Ich muss den Stream ausschalten.
Wieso kein HBA? Ich hab sogar noch welche. Ich hab sogar einen geflasht vor einem halben
Jahr oder so. Aber ich kann kein HBA einbauen. Weil, es ist kein PCI Express-Slot frei. Wenn
ein PCI Express-Slot frei wäre, dann könnte ich einen HBA einbauen. Das ist ein billiges,
ultra low budget Board. Nein, das nicht bei der Posthallzahlen. Die, also im Prinzip ist
das jetzt alles Spielerei letztendlich. Das was ich wirklich machen will, mein Heimautomatisierungszeug
da wieder drauf zum Laufen zu bringen, ist mega easy. Ich hänge einfach meine alte SATA
und lasse das D hier wieder dran, stöpsel meine drei Funk-Sticks ein, boot das Ding
und es funktioniert. Aber ich will ja gucken, ob man es nicht irgendwie noch schaffen könnte,
dem Ding 10 Gigabit, 10 Gigabit Ethernet oder 10 Gigabit Netzwerk zu entlocken. M2-Slot,
ich sag dazu nur, so siehst. Adapter-mäßig bin ich bestens bestückt. Und eigentlich
wäre dieses Board auch meine erste Wahl gewesen für so ein Gebastel. Allerdings hat dieses
Board bloß ein Dual-Core und das ist zu langsam. Ich brauch' den Quad-Core-CPU. Dual-Core ist
zu langsam. Weil wenn man denn schon ein ordentliches, also wenn ich da ein ordentliches NAS draus
baue oder wenn ich das Ding für Netzwerk-Storage verwende, dann muss das Ding ja mehrere Sachen
gleichzeitig machen. Das muss Windows-Share über Samba machen, das muss IO auf die Platte
machen und das muss Encryption-Decryption machen. Wie gesagt, ich habe euch ja schon
erzählt, dass ich seit Jahren meine Festplatten verschlüssel einfach aus dem ganz einfachen
Grund, weil ich mir dann keine Gedanken mehr machen muss, was mit der Platte passiert, wenn
ich sie irgendwie aus dem Rechner ausbaue und eben hinschmeiß. Die kann theoretisch
gerade geklaut werden, die kann ich auf den Müll schmeißen, ist egal. Also das Beste,
was man machen kann, ist tatsächlich Platte verschlüsseln. Einfach, du hast komplett
keine Sorgen mehr. Du kannst ja alles draufschieben, was du willst und kannst ja heute Abend aus
dem Fenster schmeißen und es kann keiner was mit anfangen. So deswegen, das Ding, das
muss Windows-File-Share machen, IO auf die Platte und Encryption-Decryption und halt
Rate-Logik. Und das ist zu viel für einen Dual-Core. Der ist instant am Anschlag, volle
coole. Und macht dann irgendwie 250 MB übers Netzwerk, über 10 Gigabit wohlgemerkt. Ja.
PCI-Splitter via PLX bringt mir in dem Fall auch nichts, wobei habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert,
ich denke mal, dass du damit einfach nur verschiedene Lanes aufsplittest und der PCI-Express-Slot
ist ja auch wenn das ein 16er-Slot ist, der hat ja intern nur zwei, der ist ja intern
nur mit zwei Lanes eingebunden. Das heißt, wenn ich da noch eine Lane abzwacke, dann
hätte ich zu wenig Bandbreite für eine Gigabit, für eine Gigabit-Karte. Das ist wirklich
übelste Low-End-Gefuddel, was wir hier machen, ja. Da geht nicht allzu viel, ich habe mir
da schon Gedanken zugemacht. Jaja. Äh, was? Und was ist denn das? Was ist denn das?
Äh, was? Und was nimmst du für ein Programm? Äh, Lux, das ist in Linux dabei, dann nimmst
du Crypt Setup. Crypt Setup mit ein paar Optionen und gut ist. Also immer das, immer das, was
im Kernel drin ist. Oder aber in Zukunft die Verschlüsselung, die in ZFS eingebaut ist.
Eigentlich wollte ich da eh wieder ZFS draushauen. ZFS ist jetzt erschienen in 0.8. 0.8 hat Native
Encryption dabei und ich wollte eh mal ZFS 0.8 ausprobieren. Da muss ich aber noch warten
auf Ubuntu 19.10, da ist das nämlich standardmäßig mit dabei. Ist für dein Anwendungsfall Verschlüsselung
notwendig? Na notwendig ist immer relativ. Da ist jetzt nichts irgendwie ähm großartig
schützenswertes drauf auf meinem Nass oder auf meinem Netzlaufwerk. Aber ich verschlüssel
seit Jahren schon einfach alle Platten einfach weil es sorgenfreier ist. Du kannst einfach
eine Platte nehmen, im Zweifelsfall irgendjemand in die Hand drücken, in den Schrank legen,
vergessen, dass sie drin ist, den Schrank wegschmeißen. Du musst einfach dir überhaupt
keine Gedanken mehr machen, wenn die Platten verschlüsselt sind. Deswegen verschlüsseln
ich alle Datenträger die ich hab. Was da drauf ist, da geht wahrscheinlich echt kein
Hahn danach. Welche Funksticks hast du für deine Heimautomatisierung im Eingang? Also
ich hab einmal ein Z-Wave Stick, weil ich einige Z-Wave Geräte hab, den da. Dann hab
ich einen, oh fuck, wie heißt das Ding? Duo Fernstick für meine, hab ich im letzten Video
übrigens gezeigt so ein Ding, für die Rollläden. Das ist zwar der offizielle Stick, aber da
funktioniert mit nicht offizieller Software. Das heißt man braucht das Zeug gar nicht
von denen. Dann hab ich noch dran ein, wie ist das Ding so? Ne, ach du Scheiße. Ich hab
vergessen wie das Ding heißt. Einen für 433MHz Funk, der meine andere Rolle an Steuerung
unterstützt. Ich find das Ding grad nicht. Das hab ich dran für alles was Funk auf 433MHz.
Also zum Beispiel sind das alte Steckdosenleisten, die noch per Funk gesteuert werden oder was
ist denn sonst noch so verbreitet. Keine Ahnung. Wie gesagt meine Rollläden. Dann hab
ich für Infrarot, hab ich in den Räumen wo Infrarot-Geräte drin sind, einen Prod-Com,
ne, wie heißt der Ding? Ir, so ein Ding? Ne, Prod Link. Da hab ich dann in jedem Raum
wo IR-Sachen drin sind die ich steuern will. Da sind nur 3 Räume. Hab ich so ein kleines
Ding drin stehen. Das geht über WLAN. Und die kann man aber auch mit Custom Software
verwenden. Also das heißt man braucht nicht die offizielle App. Und das ist ein wirklich
ziemlich günstiges und nicees Gerät. Die Bewertungen beziehen sich übrigens auf die
Original-Funktionen. Die Original-Funktion ist Crap. Was das Ding kann ist eigentlich
für den Preis unschlagbar. Du kannst das Ding selbst hängen sich ins WLAN und du kannst
quasi übers WLAN an das Gerät schicken was es für Infrarot-Signale senden soll. Zum
Beispiel kann ich damit meine Klimaanlage ein ausschalten. Den Modus der Klimaanlage
wechseln. Also von Kühlen auf Heizen, auf Lüften, auf Anti-Allergie und auf äh ich
glaube das wars. Wahrscheinlich ist das 5. Auto oder sowas. Du kannst damit die Temperatur
regeln, die Lüftergeschwindigkeit und theoretisch, aber das benutze ich nicht, sogar die ähm
der Luftfluss also quasi wie die Klappen gestellt sind. Jetzt kannst du alles Infrarot-Signale
damit an die Klimaanlage schicken. Und das richtig tolle ist, dass Leute auf GitHub schon
Sammlungen an IR-Codes haben. Da haben wir jetzt die Musik auf einmal übelst laut oder?
Dass auf GitHub schon Sammlungen haben für alle möglichen Klimaanlagen und da ist meine
auch dabei. Das Ding kann Fernseh einfach ausschalten, Fernseh lauter und leiser machen,
Fernseh ähm Input-Quellen umschalten. Also alles was du mit Infrarot bedienen kannst
und das ist halt richtig geil, dass man da für 20€ ein Gerät hat, was du quasi universell
in dem Raum wo es steht per WLAN-IR-Befehle absetzen lassen kannst. Das ist halt wirklich
nice. Kannst du auch Geräte manuell online jagen, geht auch. Auf GitHub gibt es eine
Software von einem für dieses Ding, also nicht das offizielle und damit kannst du Sachen
auslesen von Geräten und du kannst ihm auch Sachen beibringen. Das geht aber auch über
das Home Assistant Web Interface teilweise. Also das ist wirklich ein richtig cooles Gerät
für Leute, die selbst was bauen wollen. Irgendjemand hat gefragt, ob ich noch Geräte mit original
Firmware habe laufen lassen. Oder ob ich noch Geräte mit original Firmware laufen
lassen habe. Ja habe ich, die ganzen Raspberries, die ganzen Tür- und Fenstersensoren, die meisten
Tablets. Also ich glaube geflasht sind bloß die Fire Tablets. Leute wisst ihr was echt
erniedrigend ist? Dass ich jetzt mittlerweile hier daheim ein iPhone 6, ein iPhone XR, ein
iPhone XR, ein iPhone XR. Also mittlerweile wird immer mehr verapple-fiziert. Spielst
du auf Windows Native oder über 4M? Windows Native, spielen über 4M ist Crap, funktioniert
mit Amazon und Twitch Prime machen kann, ne?
Ja, hab ich nicht übersehen. Gut.
Ähm...
Wie findest du eigentlich Semper-Video?
Guck ich relativ selten.
Ist einer der wenigen
Channels in Deutschland, die sich mit solchen
Themen beschäftigen, deswegen find ich das ganz gut.
Der macht ja in letzter Zeit, hab ich gesehen,
relativ viele, ähm...
So, so Internetbetrugs-
Geschichten und Security-Sachen.
Ist es nicht verkehrt?
Es ist, ich muss ehrlich sagen,
es ist meistens relativ wenig Neues dabei.
Ja, aber
an sich finde ich es nicht schlecht.
Auch wenn ich, er spricht die Sachen
halt übertrieben
deutlich aus.
Ja, das ist, das ist aber
Geschmackssache.
Wie so wie ich, wo du manchmal manche
Wörter nicht verstehst, das ist ja auch nicht
Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Semper-Video würde jetzt sagen, so nach dem
Motto, ähm, warte mal, gibt's hier irgendwas
schönes, was schönes, was schönes zum
Vorlesen.
Das ist die Target
IP.
www.google.com
Die Pingsize
64.
Der sagt das halt alles so super genau,
ja.
Aber dem kann man, dem kann man dann trotzdem gut zuhören.
Ich, ich, bei mir hört sich das eher so an,
wenn ich das vorles, äh,
Tong, Tong, ja hier, thinks, äh,
okay, gut, alles klar. Habt ihr's verstanden?
So hört sich's bei mir ungefähr.
Anders als der VR, das macht schon Sinn von.
Äh,
Cooper1338 sagt, okay, also
einfach nur aus Prinzip verstehe ich.
Äh, was?
Also, ich würde an deiner Stelle
dieses SATA Port Extender verwenden,
da deine HDDs ran und mit
ZFS nen Raid machen.
SATA 3 kann circa 750, ne 500,
500, also ja 750
hast du aber, wenn du den ganzen
SCSI SATA Geschiss abziehst,
sind ungefähr noch 500 übrig, ist richtig, ja.
Äh, soll doch für einen,
ja genauso, genauso wie du das schreibst,
äh, hab ich mir das jetzt überlegt, ja.
Korrekt.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne,
BTRFS, ZFS.
BTRFS kommt mir nicht ins Haus.
Was haben wir denn jetzt?
1947,
so, Leute, also das mit dem,
mit dem Extender können wir echt noch ausprobieren.
Ähm,
also das wichtigste.
Leute, das Problem ist nur, also, ich brauche
dazu, erst mal muss ich den Extender finden.
Ich hab den irgendwo hier auf dem Riesenhaufen
Haufen mit Amazon Kartons geschmissen. Ich habe keine Ahnung wo der ist. Suche ich gleich
Extender brauche ich. Ich brauche SSDs
Und ich brauche SATA Kabel
Da könnt ihr mir jetzt mal kurz zwei Minuten wühlen zuhören
Du musst mal gucken wo das ist
Was ist das?
Ich glaube bei dem Extender sind SATA Kabel dabei. Wartet mal. Hier
Jetzt mal ASMR Unpacking
Ich packe jetzt den SATA Extender aus
SATA Extender
Ja, äh
So, SATA Extender sieht irgendwie ganz anders aus als auf Amazon
Ich glaube die haben ich jetzt gar nicht gemaßt
Wo haben wir hier Amazon?
Wobei, ne, ne, doch, das sieht, das sieht genau so aus
Okay, ich habe jetzt mal die SATA Kabel, die haben ich jetzt gar nicht gemaßt
Ich habe jetzt mal die SATA Kabel, die haben ich jetzt gar nicht gemaßt
Okay, ähm
Die Erkenntnis abonniert Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, Paulgas
Okay, also hier ist das Ding. Guck mal was da noch alles im Karton drin ist, irgendwelche komischen Schrauben die kein Mensch braucht
Und ein ganzes SATA Kabel. Huge. Und zwar das billigste vom Billigen, diese ollen, roten, kack SATA Kabel sind dabei
Und ein USB zur Stromversorgung, okay
Ja, warum nicht
Also
Ich brauche aber immer noch zwei SSDs oder zwei Magnetplatten geht auch
Okay, lass mal überlegen was brauche ich jetzt. Wir machen es mit SSDs, da können wir am besten testen wie die Bandbreite so ist
Okay, also das heißt, ich brauche noch zwei SATA Kabel und zwei SSDs, das wird sich doch auftreiben lassen
Das wird sich doch auftreiben lassen, also
Okay, eine SSD SATA Kabel habe ich schon mal
Da ist ein Disk, da ist ein Disk, 140 Giga Byte
Und jetzt brauche ich noch eine zweite SSD und da wird es ein bisschen schwieriger
Wo kriege ich eine zweite SSD noch so schnell her
Oder
Wir können auch eine Magnetfestplatte nehmen, ich habe hier gerade eine liegen
Eine zweite SSD Leute, ich brauche eine zweite SSD
Oder soll ich, oder soll ich einfach mal die Betriebssystemplatte nehmen und gucken, ob der davon booten kann
Nee, der kann davon nicht booten, oder? Kann er davon booten von so einem Ding?
Meint er, der kann von so einem Ding booten? Also ich würde die Betriebssystemplatte ehrlich gesagt ungern da dran hängen
Wollen wir mal ausprobieren, ob der davon booten kann, von diesem komischen SATA Extender
Komm, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus
Ob der davon booten könnte, wenn er davon booten kann
Da wissen wir auch, dass es auf jeden Fall funktioniert
Okay, probieren wir mal. So, da habe ich den Extender hier, dann brauche ich noch ein SATA Kabel
Was haben wir denn jetzt hier, kannste abholen
Ein SATA Kabel haben wir noch
Oh nee, es sind sogar zwei SATA Kabel, ui, nice
SATA, okay, ich, ich stapsel es mal an
Hey Max, wie hieß doch mal der Staubsauger, Roborock S15?
Komm, komm, eh
Akk.
Ok, Strom.
Gucken, ob Smokers smoket.
Die nächste sollte wieder angehen.
Und du?
Das sieht nicht so gut aus.
Ich mache mal nur eine SSD dran.
Was?
Zwei sind ein bisschen wenig.
Ich mache jetzt erst mal nur zwei Stück dran.
Ich habe jetzt nur eine SSD dran und zwar die, von der ich eben auch gebootet habe.
Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Okay, Booten über dieses Ding ist schon mal nichts, wie es aussieht.
Okay Leute, Booten darüber wird schon mal nichts.
Aber ich habe auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht vor meines System-SSD darüber anzuschließen.
Okay, MonkaS Smoke, Booten tut das hier drüber nicht.
Das heißt, ich brauche unbedingt noch eine zweite SSD, um das auszuprobieren.
Okay, ich habe es gleich.
Also wir booten jetzt erst mal wieder.
Wir booten jetzt mal wieder von der normalen SSD und danach stöpsel ich diesen Adapter
mal ein und dann gucken wir mal, wie Hotswap-fähig das ganze Zeug ist.
Also das sollte jetzt eigentlich wieder starten.
Aber ihr wisst ja, Famous Last Words, ah ne, okay es funktionierte.
Gehe alles wieder in die Kiste rein hier.
Okay, es bootet, das ist schon mal was.
Übrigens, sehr nice, dass mir gerade 269 Leute zugucken, wie ich sinnlose Dinger auf
einem Low Budget Linux-Macher mache.
Okay, jetzt schließe ich das Ding mal an, mal gucken was passiert.
Der sollte jetzt, der erkennt nichts, das ist ihm vollkommen egal, ob ich da was anschließe
oder nicht.
Das juckt ihn überhaupt nicht.
Was du in Linux machst, mache ich alles in Windows, aber ja, jedem das seine, ja.
Also das ist ihm vollkommen egal.
Vielleicht ist das China-Ding kaputt, vielleicht ist das China-Ding im Arsch, da ist natürlich
auch kein Handbuch oder irgendwas dabei, das ist ja logisch.
Muss man vielleicht, muss man das vielleicht auf der anderen Seite zuerst anschließen?
Wartet mal, ich stöpsel es mal auf der anderen Seite dran.
So, ne, das juckt es überhaupt nicht.
Also man, das kann man jetzt nicht sonderlich verkehrt anschließen, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich schließe jetzt mal, ich schließe jetzt mal die zweite SSD direkt an, ohne das China-Ding
dazwischen und dann gucken wir, ob er es erkennt.
Ups, ich hab irgendwas runtergeschmissen.
So, Moment, warum erkennt er das nicht?
Warum erkennt er die zweite SATA SSD nicht?
Okay, Reboot, immer Reboot, Reboot ist nie verkehrt.
Dann ist es doch nicht ganz so Hotswap, hm?
Also er sollte jetzt, jetzt sind beide SSDs dran, direkt onboard an dem SATA-Port, ja,
der muss die jetzt erkennen.
Wenn er die nicht erkennt, ist die SSD kaputt oder das Kabel kaputt oder...
Ja, jetzt erkennt er's.
Also die SSD ist okay, das Kabel ist okay, aber das China-Ding irgendwie nicht, das muss
man jetzt noch mal ausprobieren.
China-Skamas.
Habt ihr auch schon Erfahrungen mit, äh, mit dem, äh, mit dem, äh, mit dem, äh, mit
dem?
Habt ihr auch schon Erfahrungen mit, äh, mit, mit China-Skamas-Dingern gesammelt?
Ha.
Ah, ne, doch, jetzt hat er's erkannt, ach ja, guck mal da, jetzt hat er's erkannt, anscheinend
liegt das am Board, wenn man, das, der Board, das Board schaltet irgendwie den SATA-Port
aus, wenn man da, wenn da nix beim Booten dran war, das ist natürlich total bescheuert,
ähm.
Okay, jetzt haben wir einfach nur eine SSD, ohne was, also MKFS, machen wir hier XFS,
ist immer schon simpel, auf DEV-SDA, einfach, einfach das Ganze, ja ja, Force, einfach
das Ganze drüber bügeln, YOLO, wir machen da jetzt den XFS drauf, oh, das Ding blinkt
sich ein ab, ey, das müsst ihr ja sehen, der, der China, ey, der China-Adapter, alter,
was geht mit dem ab?
Der blitzt so, dass irgendjemand direkt epilepsische Anfälle kriegen würde, wenn er das sieht.
Okay, und jetzt mounten wir das mal und gucken wir, wie schnell eine einzelne SSD ist, ne,
es ist SATA, SATA, also 6 Gigabit, 6 Gigabits, sagen die zumindest hier, sagen, sagen die
zumindest, ne?
Gucken wir mal, die Idee, ähm, okay, ordentlich, das ist ne, das ist ne günstigere Sandisk,
ähm, alter, da stand grad Link Speed 3 Gigabit, okay, ja, vielleicht, vielleicht zu dieser,
vielleicht zu dieser SSD, das kann sein, aber das Ding ist, das Ding an sich ist, ähm,
ist ergeblich zumindest 6 Gigabit, das liegt aber, das liegt jetzt glaube ich wirklich
an der SSD, die SSDs sind echt nicht der Wahnsinn, ne, das sind, das sind, äh, Sandisk, also,
zumindest, ich guck mal, was für SSDs sind, ich glaub, so welche, ne, nicht Ultra, nicht
Ultra, normal, un-Ultra, nicht Ultra, steht nix von Ultra drauf, okay, ja, sag mal, 180
MB, äh, es geht immer weiter runter, ich muss mal, ich muss mal die Serie noch mal kurz
holen, 240, 240 Leute, 240, ja, das Ding ist das, das Ding ist das, Sandisk SSD Plus, ähm,
gucken wir uns mal ein paar Reviews an, was das Ding kriegen müsste, okay, hat er irgendwo
noch mal gescheite Daten zu, ja, die 500G ist wahrscheinlich schneller, ja, inconsistent,
was ist denn das für ein beknacktes Review ohne Benchmarkergebnisse, wollen die mir
verarschen, ja, zumindest, das ist ganz schön langsam, dann lesen wir mal was davon, ich
glaube nicht, dass das am China Adapter liegt, ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube echt, dass das,
okay, wir droppen noch mal die Caches, alle Caches weg, und dann lesen wir noch mal, gucken
wir mal, wie schnell das dann ist, aber der hauptsächliche Test kommt ja noch, ne zweite
SSD, und dann ein Rate drüber, und dann gucken wir, wie schnell das Ganze ist, okay, also
wir lesen ungefähr mit 195, na, ich dachte, es geht jetzt raus, 192MB, 194MB, 195MB, 196MB,
okay, die SSD braucht ein bisschen, um in Fahrt zu kommen, na, sagen wir mal 200MB,
das ist zum testen definitiv erstmal ausreichend, ich brauche noch eine zweite SSD, warte mal,
ich gucke mal kurz, in die Schublade, ob ich eine finde, ich habe noch eine, ich habe
noch exakt die gleiche SSD nochmal, 240GB, genau die gleiche, die schließen wir jetzt
mal an, und gucken was passiert, danke schön für die 100 Bits, ein Euro, poggers, okay,
gucken wir mal, ob er das Ganze jetzt erkennt, wenn man es jetzt direkt anschlägt, ja, das
dass, da haben wir die
Da wird gehot-swappt, nicht wirklich, eher gehot-plugged wird da.
Da ist sie, SDD und SDA.
XFS, SDD.
Da steht SATAN LINK OP 3.
Ja, es kann ja sein, es kann doch sein, dass der Link zu den Geräten 3G ist, allerdings
der Link zu, zum Host, sehen wir jetzt ja, sehen wir jetzt ja, wo hast du das gesehen
mit 3, wo stehts, ich sehe es nicht, ach hier, ja ok, mal gucken, mal gucken, mal gucken,
ok, also wir haben das andere jetzt auch XFS, wir machen jetzt mal ein MNT 2, ok, Mount
und SDD, ok und jetzt gucken wir mal, wie schnell da Kram ist, bin ich echt mal gespannt.
Also wir schreiben jetzt erst mal parallel, wir schreiben jetzt erst mal parallel, äh
was war denn das, ach das war unser Test, ich bin auch im falschen TMAX, also wir DDEen
jetzt mal nach MNT, also wir schreiben einfach nur Nullen auf die erste SSD und wir schreiben
einfach nur Nullen auf die zweite SSD und wir wissen ja schon, dass die Performance
ziemlich sackt beim Schreiben von diesen SSDs, das heißt wir müssen jetzt mal kurz
warten, bis sich das alles eingependelt hat, hey Max, wann ist mal ein neues Video geplant,
es gab doch heute ein neues, wo ich mich drüber ausgelassen hab, wie abartig ein Weisheitszahn
OP ist, lull, ok also wir wissen das Schreiben war vorher auch schon nicht schnell, das Lesen,
das Lesen, müssen wir jetzt mal gucken, ich lass den mal, ich lass den mal ein paar Gigabyte
schreiben, lass den mal irgendwie so 7, 8G schreiben, das Maximum über SATA 2 sind dann
was 250 MB oder so, ok das reicht, ok jetzt machen wir das einfach mal umgedreht, if das
nicht klappt, dann machen wir das einfach mal, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
Blöcke, ich glaube von richtigen Blöcken kann man ja bei SSDs eh nicht sprechen
Tja Leute, ich würde mal sagen, der China Adapter hat uns ganz schön Skamast
Der China Adapter Skamast uns ganz schön, weil wir wir kommen ziemlich genau beim Maximum raus
von SATA 2. Ziemlich ziemlich genau
Da würde ich sagen, die haben uns gescannt
Wir lesen jetzt ja noch mal einer, der müsste jetzt auch schneller sein
Ja
Ehe, es scammed alle
Stimmt einfach nicht, was drauf steht
Einfach gebadet
Wenn die SSDs nur einen 3 Gigabit Link haben, die SSDs sollten aber eigentlich einen 6 Gigabit Link haben
Das können wir mal ausprobieren, indem wir einfach die SSD direkt anschließen
Oder hat jemand drauf geachtet, was passiert?
Hat jemand geguckt, ob die SSDs mit SATA 3 sünken?
Also ich weiß, dass die SSDs haben theoretisch SATA 3
Probieren wir mal aus
Gebadet
Warum ist die nur, warum ist die SSD, warum sünkt die sich nur mit SATA?
Okay, der spackt noch rum
Der spackt gerade rum, weil ich im laufenden Betrieb rausgezogen habe und wieder dran gesteckt habe
Ich glaube, das mag der nicht so
Ich glaube, das ist nicht so die gute Idee gewesen
Ah, guck hier, die Chinesen haben uns scammast, der Adapter ist nur SATA 3, obwohl SATA 6 dran steht
Scammed bei Chinamann
Schicke ich wieder zurück an Amazon
Ich habe mich gerade gewackelt kontaktet
Anzeige ist raus, er ist offensichtlich
Wir probieren jetzt mal was aus
Wir gucken jetzt mal, wie schnell das Ding ist, wenn es direkt per SATA angeschlossen ist
Mounten wir jetzt mal SDE
Ja gut, das ist jetzt das Maximum wahrscheinlich, was die SSD schafft
Die Chinesen haben uns gescampt
Amazon Riture ist direkt unterwegs
Chinas Gammas
Was schreiben die denn hier dabei?
Die schreiben eindeutig, 6 Port, SATA 3, 6 Gigabit
Eindeutig
Klar schicke ich die wieder zurück
Was soll ich mit so einem Kack
SATA 2 habe ich noch 4 Stück oder 5 Stück hier rumliegen von den China Port Multiplier
Die habe ich mir von AliExpress bestellt für irgendwie 4 Euro das Stück
Und den wollte ich einfach nur mal schnell haben und ausprobieren, der ist viel zu teuer
hier
Weil er angeblich SATA 3 bzw. 6G kann
Und nachdem er jetzt kein 6G kann
Ist es komplett unsinnig
Guck mal Modell, da steht irgendwas von Modell drauf
Ich schau mal
Ja guck hier 290 MB
Hallo Benji Shooter
Ich guck mal kurz da drauf, was da für eine Nummer drauf steht
Ich habe sie mir was anderes geschickt
Was soll da drauf stehen Modell, ADP
Das ist China Kram, da steht überhaupt nichts drauf
Es sieht aber wirklich exakt so aus
Aber wahrscheinlich sieht halt auch die SATA 3 Version original so aus wie die SATA 2 Version
Äh
Ich kann das nicht erkennen
Ich muss da mal kurz drauf leuchten mit meinem Handy
Auf dem Bild ist ein Modell angegeben, wo
Also von dem Chip her ist es exakt das gleiche
Ach da oben rechts
Habe ich gerade nicht gesehen
Aha, she baited
Sogar ihr eigenes Produktbild ist falsch
Ja, da habe ich auch gerade angehört Kupa, der Camp los SATA 2
Das ist einfach she baited
Zumal das ja auch nicht das hier ist
Sondern ein anderer
China Scamas
Das Ding geht instant zurück
Haben die denn vielleicht bei Amazon noch mehr, die man holen könnte, die nicht Scamas
sind
War das das Scamas
Ne guck, die machen es richtig, die schreiben 3G
Die schreiben auch SATA 2
Die hier schreiben auch SATA 3G, ja
Nur die hier
Die hier, die hier Scamasen, die bescheißen
Tja, China, man
Haben die sonst noch irgendwelche Sachen
Weil es gibt die Dinger, es gibt die Dinger mit 6G
Ich hatte nur keinen Bock AliExpress zu bestellen und dann irgendwie einen Monat darauf warten
zu müssen
Die machen nämlich alle plus 3G hier
Oh, der macht angeblich auch 6G
Ja, der kommt aber auch direkt aus China geschickt
Da kann er ja auch direkt bei AliExpress bestellen
Weil bei AliExpress kostet der Kram nix
Ok, die kommen alle aus China
Kommen alle aus China hier
3G, ja
Richtiger G-Bate
SATA Port Multiplier
Aber eine schöne Sache daran ist
Dass man wissen, dass die China Port Multiplier an dem Board funktionieren
Das heißt, wenn die 2 auffunktionieren, werden nur die mit SATA 3 auffunktionieren
Guckt hier, so einen brauchen wir
Der kostet einfach auch nur weniger als die Hälfte auf AliExpress
Und versandt ganze 51 Cent
Heißer, heißer Controller-Karte
Uiuiuiui, ist aber heiß die Controller-Karte
Guck, hier schreiben sie sogar drauf
Explicit SATA 3
Ja, und hier steht auch J05
Das ist die eigentliche Karte, die wir hätten bekommen sollen
Aber wir haben die alte bekommen
Ok, wie lang dauert der Versand?
Ha, 4, ha, 4 reicht auch
Ist klar
Der Versand dauert halt fucking lang, ne
Vor allem, warum dauert das mit Tracking länger als mit Turkey-Post
Dauert einfach mal einen Monat länger
Freund, Zugucker
Äh, B29-Korn, ich hab da auch schon mal einen Monat drauf gewartet
Also schon öfters
Kommt immer ganz drauf an
Wobei, ach stimmt, wir, Moment, wir haben ja schon Oktober
Ich hab's ja voll vergessen
Übrigens, danke für den Twitch-Prime-Sub
Singapur-Post, wieso dauert doch länger, neben das, was am schnellsten da ist
Das geht eigentlich, das ist auch tatsächlich gar nicht so langsam
Aber Leute, dadurch, dass wir Oktober haben, soll ich euch mal was Tolles erzählen
Ähm, ich hab jetzt die Woche, hier hab ich jetzt noch frei, das heißt, ich muss dann
noch, dieses Jahr muss ich noch 1, 2, 3, 4, ne, 4, 5, 6, 7 Wochen arbeiten, dann, Moment,
Fuck, falsche Richtung
Knackter Pfeiler, ok, Moment, falsch
Ähm, also, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 8 Wochen, hä?
8 Wochen muss ich noch arbeiten, dann hab ich den kompletten Dezember frei
Dezember frei, das ist massive Poggers, huge big-prime Poggers
Ok, Leute, ähm, leider wurden wir vom China-Mann scamaßt, vom China-AliExpress
Oder, na, von AliExpress wurden wir nicht scamaßt, vom, vom, vom AliExpress-China-Verkäufer
über Amazon wurden wir scamaßt, äh, es stimmt halt gar nicht, so ein Adapter hätt
ich mir nie gekauft, hätt ich gewusst, dass der SATA 2 ist
Tja, macht's gut, ich hau ab, wir sehen uns, bis, vielleicht mach ich morgen schon direkt
ein neues Video
Wir sehen uns bis dahin, macht's gut, C.O.
Bis dahin, macht's gut, C.O.
Bis dahin, macht's gut, C.O., bis dahin, macht's gut, C.O., bis dahin, macht's gut, C.O.,
bis dahin, macht's gut, C.O., bis dahin, macht's gut, C.O., bis dahin, macht's gut, C.O., im
Das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss!